- I got hit in the head with a shovel.
- [Joey] You got hit on
the head with a shovel?
How hard are we talking right,
just like a little like boop or?
- (bonk) Great weapon.
but if you hit it with the concave side,
it's not that bad on your skull.
(chill music playing)
- Did we do a soundcheck?
- Oh yeah we did.
- Okay.
- Wait, were you not paying attention?
- No.
- All right.
- I was waiting for you
to get out of the shitter.
That's what I was doing.
- I refuse to get out
of the shitter, Garnt.
- Getting out of the shitter.
(giggling)
You're all right?
- Yeah mate.
I'm ready to go.
I heard to word rolling.
I'm looking down at this camera.
- Oh okay.
Man, he's more professional
than we are, all right.
- Should we count it in?
Should we give it a,
I'll count it in. Okay.
- Sure go for it.
- All right?
- [Connor] He's way more
serious than we are.
- All right, we're rolling.
Quiet on set.
All right, and we're live
in five, four, three.
- Hello everyone! welcome
back to another episode
of Trash Taste podcast.
I'm your host for this week,
for the first time in a while.
And with me are the boys as usual.
And we have a guest.
Introduce yourself.
- Hi! Hello Trash Taste podcast
listeners and video viewers.
my name is Ladybeard.
I'm thrilled to be here today
on the Trash Taste podcast.
- Jesus Christ.
- Normally we have to like
bring the energy to the guests.
I feel like I'm being brought up.
- No Ladybeard brought the energy dammit.
Bloody hell, I came with all
the energy you can handle.
You won't be able to shut me up.
That old lady at Denny's
told us we had to be quiet.
- We've never had that happen to us.
- That's how this started
for viewers at home.
We had a, a pre-production
meeting in Denny's
and the old lady came up and told us.
- That's a generous of
wording the pre-production.
- It's just a lunch.
- We ate lunch at Denny's
before we did this.
And the old lady who works at Denny's
made a point of coming up to
us to tell us, that we were.
- No no, she made a point
of coming up to you.
- I'm so sorry, we're regulars there.
We can't go back there now.
- You can't I've ruined it for you.
- They know our schedule.
We go there and there's
a guy who just knows
the exact time and like
the exact day that we come.
- Yeah.
When we come early he's like, Oh
you're a bit early than usual.
- That's great. That's fantastic.
You're regulars. That's wonderful.
Are we allowed to, am I allowed to say
the general area of Japan,
which the studio was in?
- No.
We're in Japan.
- Okay we're in Japan
in the same general area
that we're in right now.
I actually have a reputation
of ruining things for people because.
- Why?
- Well one of my best friends lives
in this general area too.
- And so it was at night when I went
to his house and we
played this game where.
Sorry. Okay.
- Oh God.
- No, what the fuck.
- I'm scared now.
- We play this game when
we went walking out,
it's the middle of summertime,
about two, three in the morning
we went out to do the convenience store
and the things you normally do.
And we played this game of, you know,
there's only certain
institutions that are open
at that time of day.
- Right, right.
- So we made this game
when we would go into the institution,
you know, in Japan they
have the little tray
to put your money in when you pay for.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We made this game out.
We go and we'd do whatever,
buy our stuff at the convenience store.
And then we would flip over the tray
and see how they reacted.
Cause a lot of people in Japan
people working in the service industry,
can't handle that.
- Right.
(everyone laughing)
- It blew minds you see.
I remember saying to the
guy at the convenience store
It was, it was probably a bit nasty
because my friend is this
huge body builder guy
and I'm a pro wrestler.
So we're there,
and the dude behind the
convenience store, it's 3:00 AM.
It's two foreigners.
There's no other humans for miles around.
And he's this tiny little dude.
And I'm like, but what would you do, sir?
If I did, this.
And I flipped the tray, and just waited.
- Whilst he was looking,
like you were maintaining eye contact?
- This poor man freaked out.
He freaked out.
He will never talk to
a foreigner ever again.
Anyway, but that the game became
you would run into an institution,
you flip the tray and run out.
And you would see what would happened.
- So, Basically just ding-dong dashing.
- Yeah, well it means
now my friend can't go
to a Tsutaya anymore.
- What? Because he's
known as that giant dude
who flips trays over.
- You know the Arnold Schwarzenegger meme
when he was running with his shirt off?
Can you imagine, you see guys
running to the restaurant
just to flip over table then running out.
(everyone laughing)
- Okay but, first of all,
I think there's going to
be a lot of confusion.
- We just jumped right into it.
- Yeah, let's, let's dial back a bit.
- Let's go back a bit.
Do you want to introduce yourself
to audiences who don't know
who you are or what you do?
- What do you do? Why are
you wearing this outfit?
- Because to someone who doesn't
because to someone who
doesn't know who Ladybeard is,
they're probably just thinking
who's this white guy in a dress?
- Who is this random Aussie?
Who just joined the Trash Taste podcast?
- I'll be honest.
I don't know anything.
I want to come into this blind.
I want to hear and meet you
and experience everything.
So I know absolute nothing about you.
- I'm Connor's biggest fan.
- Shit.
- Connor has made me so happy
in the short time I've known him.
Let me introduce myself.
- Go for it.
- Watch this, I'll do it
like where like we're on TV.
This is channel seven right here.
- Okay go for it.
(Ladybeard clears throat)
- My name's Ladybeard.
I'm a heavy metal singer and pro wrestler
from Australia currently based in Japan.
Today I'm thrilled to be
talking to my friends.
- This is the quietest you've been.
It's very creepy.
This the quietest you've
been in a long time.
- That was like Australian news
documentary narration voice.
- It was, wasn't it?
But I didn't go up at
the end of my sentence.
The way I potentially should have.
- Like every Australian does.
- So up here in Australian media.
We're in Japan so there's no need
to talk about the wonderful
nation of Australia
from which both, Joseph and I, hail.
- We can get to that though.
We can get to that.
- So how does this,
come to be what is this?
- So, so I am a heavy metal
singer and a pro wrestler.
And a cross-dresser.
- Wait, which one were you first?
- I was first a cross-dresser.
- Oh, really?
- And then became a
cross-dressing pro wrestler
and then became a
cross-dressing wrestling,
heavy metal singer.
- What is, what is the journey?
- I feel like you're saying
these steps so casually
and I'm trying to break these down.
- That's like, that's
like someone being like,
I was a straight man and
then I was a straight man
who became an astrophysicist.
And then I became a straight
man who does astrophysicist
and does gardening every now and then.
- Are you not those things?
- Yes.
- I thought that's what this was.
- I feel like there's a story that gets us
from point A to point B,
but I'm just not seeing it.
- So I, okay.
I used to live in the city of Hong Kong
and I was an actor and a voice
actor and a pro wrestler.
- Whoa, Whoa, Whoa.
- How do you get to Hong Kong?
- No, no, now you're adding
like five more different points this time.
- Okay! If you want an
abbreviated version of the story
so is to avoid these
pitfalls we're currently in.
- You just created more pitfalls.
- I want to know, what
made you leave Australia?
Let's start there.
- Okay. So I went through
acting school in Australia,
to be an actor.
- Okay.
That's mainly what acting
school's for, mainly.
- Makes sense.
- But I also am a martial artist.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- And so what happened was I,
then I moved from Adelaide,
that's where I'm from, I
trust Joey he will know,
is a small city.
- Yes.
- To Melbourne.
- Right.
- Joey will know.
- Is a big city.
- A bigger city.
- This isn't a child's
series, what is this?
- So I was training in,
in Hong Kong style, like cinematic action
with this is Aussie dude who was
on Jackie Chan's stunt team, right?
- So I was on his stunt team, right?
And basically was no
work factors in Australia
at the time.
So I'm there on auditioning on things.
And I'm auditioning against
like Aussie celebrities
and things, cause there's
no way as a school leaver,
I'm going to get a bloody job.
So the stunt dude I was
training with, he was like
you should go to Hong Kong
cause worst case scenario you'll go there,
you'll get a bit of
work because it's easier
cause you're a foreigner,
so you got less competition.
Then you can come back here
and be more employable.
You can go to auditions, right?
And they'd be like, yeah, you're good.
But you need experience.
Catch 22, How are you gonna get experience
when they don't give
you experience, right?
So it's like
they told me somehow you
have to get experience.
We're not going to help you.
All right.
So anyway, so I went to Hong Kong playing
just do a couple of
movies and then come home.
I ended up staying six years.
- You say that so casually.
- Well it was much more
work to be had in Hong Kong
than it was at home.
- Right, right, right.
- You said, you just like
stayed around a mate's house.
(everyone laughing)
Yeah, went there for a bit
and just stayed for six years.
- I went to Hong Kong, I flipped the tray
and I run out again.
(everyone laughing)
- So it was just a case
you just kept getting work
in Hong Kong.
- Yeah well, there's much more to do there
there's much more to do there.
But so this is true.
So I went in 2006.
I had a brief stint when
I moved to the Philippines
cause I got a job offer down there
to work at a movie studio.
- Right, right, right.
- But then I was there
for about six months
and I went back to Hong
Kong doing my stuff.
But then, then.
- And this was mainly doing
like martial arts and?
- Martial arts, acting, voice
acting, and stunt, right.
- So a little bit of everything.
- Yeah. Well, through acting school
you learn to be an actor,
you learn voice acting.
Then I was a martial artist.
So I learned stunts at
the back of that, right.
So then,
but then, so then go 2006,
six, seven, eight, I'm there.
And then 2008 along comes
that global financial crisis.
And wipes out everything I had going on.
- Yeah.
- So I'm like, all right, well
nothing to go back to at home
now there's nothing here.
What am I going to do?
And I made the logical choice
of realizing the way to
solve all my problems
was to become a
cross-dressing pro wrestler
and heavy metal singer.
- Okay. So,
how did you, how did you
come to that realization?
- Like this is not natural.
I think most people, pack it in boys.
Just go and get a job at Tesco, you know.
- Okay, let's take it one
step at a time, right?
Like so, have you always had,
I assume you've always had a
fascination towards wrestling?
- Yep. So martial artist obviously.
- And also performer.
And stunt man.
So really pro wrestling is like
a small skip and jump from here.
- I was always interested in
wrestling when I was younger
but it just due to where
I lived in Adelaide
and where the wrestling gyms were,
they were miles away.
So I never had the
chance to actually do it.
- Did you watch like
WWE and stuff like that?
- Yeah. But that wasn't,
when I was at the age
to watch all that
it wasn't on TV very
readily in, in Adelaide.
It was on like 1:30 in the morning.
On a Thursday.
So it's like, you know.
- Only the naughty kids
stay up to watch that.
- When I was up, "studying",
I will yeah, catch the WWE sometimes.
But, your of a different
generation than I, I think.
Without giving up too many things.
So the wrestlers you watched
are probably different
from the ones I watched.
- I mean to be frank,
I didn't really watch a
whole lot of wrestling.
- You do assume that I do
watch wrestling before, right?
- I mean.
Okay. My wrestling knowledge
of like back you know,
when I was like in teenage years.
All of it comes from all the WWE games
that my neighbor used to have.
- Okay, okay.
- So like, you know, it'd be
like back then when it was
I think it was still
"SmackDown vs. Raw", right.?
Like that kind of like level,
so it's like, very, I wouldn't
call myself a wrestling fan.
- But that's around the time
when I was getting access
to this 1:30 in the morning.
- Right, right, right.
- But you had to have
Foxtel to be able to watch
the damn wrestling.
I didn't have Foxtel.
- Yeah.
Foxtel is like a
- It's like cable.
- Like cable.
- Like Sky? That's what I thought so.
- Yeah, like Sky, basically.
- But then Australia Sky is
that conservative news network.
So don't say sky.
Cause that's a very
different thing in Australia.
- I don't even know that.
- You don't know it?
- No.
- Too many people use the same words
for their media outlets.
- So wait, okay.
So then, I want to know
then if that's the case.
Okay. So you're like,
so okay, so you're like into
wrestling and you're like, okay
it's just a logical progress
to go into wrestling.
- Yeah.
- So then wait, how do you, okay.
I've always wondered
because I know a few people
who like used to be pro wrestlers
or currently do pro wrestling.
- Okay.
- How do you even start to get
into an industry like that?
- Well, you go in, you
go to wrestling school.
So you go to a wrestling gym
and you'll do a tryout to see
whether or not they will train you.
- All right.
- And if they accept you,
then they accept you.
And they start training you.
- What do they look for?
What's like, what's like
the audition process?
- Well you do need to have, you know,
physically, you need to be able
to handle the physical stuff.
And then, you know, from a,
I guess a presentation of
performance perspective
you need to have some
level of aptitude in that.
Yeah. You don't necessarily
need to be trained
in anything already,
but if you're super shy
and you can't handle being
in front of an audience
it's not going to work out great.
Cause wrestling is
generally speaking about
larger than life characters.
- Yeah.
- And men in dresses.
Or Man in dresses.
- That's right.
- So how did you go from
that to moving to Japan then?
- So, okay.
So, Financial crisis,
all the work's gone.
But around that time, I
started wrestling in Hong Kong
cause there was a gym
that was accessible to me
for the first time.
Started wrestling.
Started training a month later,
I caught on fairly quickly
cause the techniques are not
that different from stunts.
A month later I had my first match.
- And so, yeah, that's too fast.
Anyone who's training wrestling,
a month is too fast.
- I feel like a month is
too fast for any training.
- Let's go from your first body slam
to doing it in front of people.
- Right, right, right.
- When you say first wrestling match,
is this like a whole coordinated this,
you do this I do this, kind of thing?
Or was it literally just
like, how does that work?
I have no idea.
- Where so in wrestling, it's a, okay.
So there's like a system, right?
- Once you learn the system,
then you can work.
So if I know what I'm doing,
if I'm trained to the system
and you're trained to the system,
we could have never have met before.
But we can,
we know the system.
- Yeah, right, right, right.
- It's all right.
It's all right, Connor.
- I don't fucking know.
- No, no, I want it to know as well.
- Yeah.
I mean, you know, cause it's, it's an act
but it's not an act, right?
- Are you telling me that
wrestling is fake, Connor?
- Oh my God.
- This is Connor McGregor, right here.
It's MMA, it's the real thing.
Connor McGregor, top of the morning to ya.
I though this was the
Joe Rogan experience.
What's going on?
And Connor, what's going on?
It's a podcast.
I was lied to.
- What is happening?
(everyone laughing)
I didn't want to offend you.
- I'm so confused right now.
- Connor McGregor. Connor. Connor.
- I'm losing my mind already.
- I am Connor, Connor's largest fan.
If your last name is not McGregor,
what should I call you by your last name?
- Ladybeard is literally in every
Ladybeard is in like,
and I, and I say this
in the nicest way possible,
is one of the hardest people to work with.
(everyone laughing)
Oh, shit.
- Oh, no.
- Like I just said, like
I literally just said
this man is like fucking
destroying our set.
- Destroying the set within.
- Jesus Christ.
- 15 minutes in recording.
- My legs, my legs.
Can't walk correctly.
- All right, let's cut so we can fix this.
- Sorry.
- So what re we talking
about before that calamity?
Wrestling, we're talking about wrestling.
- How it works,
then of course You were
saying about, you know
you had one month of training
before your first match.
- That's right yeah, yeah.
So then we're there and we're discussing
before this match, okay.
So what do you want your character to be?
Your gimmick as it's
referred to pro wrestling.
And,
I have a long history in cross dressing.
- Yeah. So can we talk about that?
- We, we completely missed that.
We forgot.
- Yeah. So how did that come to be?
- So when I was 14, a friend of mine
had a school uniform birthday
party, and I thought.
- Wait, what's a school
uniform birthday party?
- Have you never been
to a party in your life?
- No. But like, what do
you mean by school uniform?
- That was nasty, I didn't mean to.
Cut that, cut the Ladybeard aggression.
I didn't mean aggression to Joey.
I'm sorry, Joey.
- No it's fine.
- I secretly love you.
- It's okay.
I just, I just genuinely
wanted to know what
a school uniform School
uniform day party is.
What is that?
- A school uniform birthday party
is a birthday party to
which everybody wears
school uniform.
- Isn't that just like, a normal party?
- Isn't that just like
an after-school party?
- Yeah.
- Yeah. But you don't go after school.
It's like on the weekend or whatever.
- What I want to know is
why you wanted to choose
to wear a school uniform to go to a party?
- Cause it was my friend's birthday.
And she can do it if she wants to.
So it's her party, she
can cry if she wants to.
You would cry too if it happened to you.
- Okay, okay.
- So you went to a school
uniform birthday party.
- I went to the school
And I saw all my mates went
wearing what we wore to school.
So wearing the trousers and the blazer
and the shirt and everything.
- Yup, yup.
- And I was like, it'd be really funny
if I wore my big sister school dress.
So I did.
And it was a hit amongst the 14 year olds.
- Yeah. That'd be hilarious.
- Yeah, it was hilarious, right?
It was. Yeah.
And so, then what
happened is I started then
wearing that particular school dress
to various other
non-school uniform parties.
Rock and roll shows and things.
And what happens is, I noticed that
this is back in the nineties.
So it's a different time from now.
As a man in a dress, young man in a dress
I will walk into the room
and the energy of the room
would lift straightaway.
So you know how at the
start of every party
there's like that two
hours of faffing around
when everyone's not really loose
and everyone's got a.
That would just disappear,
dude the dress walk in.
They would go, OH! Dude in a dress!
(everyone laughing)
And the party's on, straightaway, right?
- Right, right.
- Wooh!
You know, 6:00 PM.
Wooh!
- So you were like the party
starter at like every party.
- Yeah. It was great.
- I can see that.
- I mean, this kind of what
I do on my YouTube channel.
- Exactly.
- Right?
- It's fun, I don't know,
it's freeing, you know.
You feel like when you're the
clown, you can do anything.
You know what I mean?
- What? You do what?
You cross dress on your YouTube channel?
- I've done a lot of cross
dressing on my YouTube channel.
- Oh I see.
- It's quite fun.
I mean, I feel like
when your, when you know
you're the butt of the
joke, it's so like, I dunno
it's sort of like freeing,
it's so controlled.
Like, cause you feel like
you're the one in control.
- Yeah, that's not how I felt it.
For me it was not butt of the joke.
But I appreciate what
you're saying though.
I appreciate what you're saying.
But definitely when you're
the object of attention.
- Yeah.
- What I found,
see it's become a different
conversation recently
because the whole transgender
movement is happening.
So now it's a different conversation
from what it was when I started.
But for me it was a case of,
I was more successful at life
when wearing a dress
then when wearing pants.
Which is an interesting thing, really.
Cause a lot of transgender people
would have the opposite experience.
They say they wanted to express themselves
by wearing dresses or whatever.
And then they felt they couldn't.
But for me, I was dressed
like a dude and it was like.
And then I put on a dress and I was like.
- I think there's a lot of insecurity
out there with guys where they're like,
if you say it's a joke, it's hilarious.
But if you're like, no, I like this.
They're like, Oh, I don't
know how to feel about that.
There's some of that.
- I mean, just talking to you now,
you definitely bring the
energy wherever you go.
- Thank you.
- So, I think I feel it
played the part into it.
- Thank you, Garnt.
- I don't think the dress
is needed for the energy.
- We'll stay like this for
the rest of the podcast.
- Yeah, I feel it's like
the energy was there
before the skirt came on, you know.
- But sort of like on what you just said.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. But I turn up in
this and I'm all energetic.
Everybody goes, well, that makes sense.
But when I just turn up in pants
an old lady in Denny's
tells me to shut up.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
You know what I'm sayin'?
Right. Am I wrong?
Am I wrong?
- I mean.
- I am curious.
- I think, I think the outfit
wouldn't have mattered.
- I think she would tell
you to shut the fuck up.
- I am curious in the
country of noise complaints
how many noise, just how many
noise complaints have you got?
- Oh dear me, dear me.
It's a non-stop stream
of noise complaints.
Walking down the street,
(speaking in Japanese)
just constantly.
Constantly.
- How do you not like, I don't know,
cause I guess, you know,
you had that like voice
acting experience, right?
So I guess like the whole, like, you know
using your voice and being
loud and all of that,
it's just like kind of
ingrained into you, almost.
- I don't know, I just save that shit.
What do you mean?
That's optional.
- Yeah. But it's,
I think it's more just
a personality trait.
- Personality trait. Yeah.
- And on top of that,
I'm a younger sibling.
So I had to do something
to get some damn attention.
- Look at me!
- Frankly! Frankly!
So, where am I in this story?
Yeah. So, okay.
So I was a casual cross-dresser
and then when I moved to Hong Kong
I started cross-dressing
at the same capacity.
So just going out to rock and roll shows
or things in a dress.
Cause Hong Kong is such
a conservative society
that if I lifted the energy in Australia,
in Hong Kong, I really lifted the energy.
- Oh, I walk in.
It was just, AHH!
People just lost their minds.
You're the funniest person
I have ever seen in my life.
They went bonkers for it.
So I'm like, damn!
So, so there we are.
And we're figuring out characters
for the first wrestling match.
Every other wrestler,
every other wrestler in Hong Kong
their gimmick was, I am a wrestler.
- Right?
- Right.
- So I'm like.
- Like nothing interesting at all.
- Yeah, exactly, he's a wrestler.
Is that all? Yes.
Okay.
So I'm like.
- What are you good at? I wrestle.
- What is your name? Wrestler.
- The wrestler.
(everyone laughing)
- So I'm like, I'm gonna wear a dress
and then going to be called Ladybeard.
- Right.
- So all the other wrestlers were like
Ahh, okay.
And they were weird about it, right?
First match I go in there.
Overnight, most popular
wrestler in Hong Kong.
- Damn.
- Cause I was the only
one who had a character.
- Right, right.
- Cause everyone else was,
a wrestler the same as
the other 20 wrestlers
they just seen come out before him.
- So what I want to know, is like,
I assume this is like the
amateur wrestling scene.
How did they, how did they
introduce new wrestlers?
And what's the process for that?
- Well, Okay. So like I say,
you go through you, you do a, a tryout
and if they agree to train
you, you start training.
And then when you get,
when you're kind of released publicly
as in when you're debut.
They'll find a way to debut you.
So normally you do it
with something public
like a wrestling show
or like a video segment
or something like that.
And they'll just like,
whoever you are in the ring
and however you're going
to fit into the company
and the stories and so forth.
They'll just find a way that works
to introduce your character.
So let's say for instance, right now
let's say we've been training Garnt and,
for the past year
and Garnt's now a skilled
young pro wrestler.
- As you can see my physique right here.
- You can see Garnt's
been smacking at the gym
on a daily basis.
So, okay.
So what's, let's make a
gimmick for you real quick.
You are the, the Thai elephant God.
So, Okay.
He's the Thai elephant
God, and we've decided
and currently, Joey
who is the slightly
colorful haired luchador.
(everyone laughing)
- Okay.
- He's in a feud with,
Connor, the Welsh despair.
- Just, just being Welsh.
- So you two are feuding,
you two are feuding
- Why does the Welsh despair
sounds so cool, right?
- I'm trying to think of
a word that start with W
but I couldn't think of it in two seconds.
- I'm the multicolored luchador.
Like what the fuck?
- What would you like to be?
- I don't, anything else
would be really fine.
- Really?
- Other than what's your gimmick?
I have interesting colored hair.
(everyone laughing)
Cool. Thanks.
- Is that the standard
of Hong Kong gimmick?
- That didn't even have
interesting colored hair.
- Sorry, I don't mean to sound rude.
I apologize to my wrestling
brothers in Hong Kong.
Anyway, okay. So let's
say you guys are feuding.
We'll find some kind of angle in which,
during your story,
for some reason,
the Thai elephant God
is paying huge homage
to the multicolored luchador.
And to that end, when
you guys are in a match
Joey will hit his finisher
and he'll like, cover Connor.
It will be one, two,
and then the lights will
go off and they'll come on
and riding down the ramp on an elephant
is the Thai elephant God.
To let everybody know,
that the match is not
going to end like this.
Or just any damn way you want to do it.
This is one of the beautiful
things about wrestling.
There's a lot of potential for
creativity and so forth so.
- So did you get to
like, say for instance,
like the entry, right?
Like I think from what I've
heard, like each wrestler
they, do they get to choose
what song they enter with?
- Yeah. It depends on your company really.
- Right, right.
But like, but like you,
basically the wrestler
like every other time,
like they get to choose
how they want to enter.
- I personally got to.
But of course you're limited by, you know
what you're capable of doing.
- Copyright, I imagine?
- Oh yeah, true, true, true.
- That can be a problem
if it's a, well, yeah,
it can be a problem, but it's kind of like
if you're small time, you're
often too, too small time.
If you're big time, they've
got the rights cleared, so.
- So what's like, say
like for you, for example,
like what's like your pinnacle of entries
that you remember?
Because I've seen some, cause recently,
Aki has been getting into WWE,
which is like slightly worrying as well.
Because I'm like, is she
going to be a WWE girlfriend?
I don't know about that.
But she was watching,
we were watching, like, I
think it was like the top 10,
like WWE, like most memorable WWE entries.
And the one that fucking killed me
was one that John Cena did
where they literally somehow got
a hundred John Cena lookalikes
to come out in this, like,
like just this fucking row of people.
And they would part ways
and create this like aisle.
- That's the most excellent thing.
- They'd part ways and create this aisle.
And then the moment
the fireworks went off,
they all turned to each other
and start doing this.
- That's fantastic.
- And then John, the real
John Cena comes down,
he just runs through
them all just doing this.
- That's fantastic. That's fantastic.
- Did you ever get to do
something like that or?
- Well, let me tell you something Joey,
the budget that's been
dedicated to let me in
is not the same as the one
that has been dedicated
to John Cena.
- Okay, then what, what
would you say is like,
yeah, this is like the peak of my entry.
- Of like a ring entrance?
- Of like a ring entrance.
- I dunno. I don't
think I've done anything
particularly special as a ring entrance.
- You don't really like -
- Off the top of my head.
No, I don't think I've
ever really done any.
- Nothing? You just, you
just kind of show up?
- Hey guys.
- Hey, homie.
- Hey, I'm Ladybeard.
- Get announced, you know, come out,
get big light on you.
- Yeah.
- Go around high-fiving
the audience into ring
but you gotta remember when I come out
I've got pigtails in and
a pink and white bikini.
So just that is somewhat
a statement my friend.
- True, true, true.
- I don't need to do this, Joey.
Everyone's looking already.
- I want them to see me.
(everyone laughing)
All right, so.
- Terrible, terrible.
- Only terrible WWE jokes.
So, okay.
So we established the
cross dressing thing.
We've established the pro wrestling thing.
Metal singing. How did that come to be?
- So when I moved to Hong Kong,
I started learning Cantonese
cause that's the language I speak there.
And so one of the strategies I had
for learning languages
was I would get music
in that language, which I'm
sure you guys are probably going
through here with Japanese?
Not Connor from the look on his face.
But you kept music that
you like in the language.
So I started listening
to Cantonese pop songs.
Most of the music is pop,
there's very little
anything else in Hong Kong.
So I'm listening to these pop songs.
And my favorite ones are
metal head and way back.
Actually my favorite songs full stop,
were always like metal
covers of pop songs.
- Right, right, right.
- So like, you know metal covers
of like last Friday night.
Poker face and things like that.
Cause they're hilarious, right?
Cause you're so used to hearing
Lady Gaga with, you know
♪ Can't read my poker face ♪
and then you hear,
♪ You can't read my poker face ♪
To me, it's so funny right?
I think it's fantastic.
Because it takes what you're
used to and it subverts it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's a thing of beauty.
So when I started listening
to these Cantonese pop songs
I was like, these are really catchy songs.
Who's done the metal covers?
It turns out no one had.
- Right.
- And I was like.
- Free real estate, isn't it?
- Three years later.
- I, it was after the financial crisis
everything had been wiped out.
I'm like, what am I going to do?
I was going through one of those exercises
where you figure out your career
and what you're going to do.
And it's like, what are
you passionate about?
And I'm like, well, heavy
metal and destroying things.
So I'm like, okay, I want
to be a metal singer.
And I was like, okay,
specifically I want to sing metal covers
of Cantonese pop songs.
Because I think they'll sound awesome.
No one else has done it.
I'm gonna goddamn do it.
So I did.
And then what I said was, okay,
so I've already got
this fan base organized
with the wrestling.
I'm going to do this metal project
as Ladybeard and I'm gonna
bring that fan base over.
And then I'm going to
try and do this amazing
interesting thing of working
the pro wrestling world
and the heavy metal world together.
So that the storylines interlock
and they flow back and
forth between worlds.
- This tells to me you're 15
years too early to TikTok.
- Yeah.
- I feel like those heavy metal covers
will blow up on TikTok.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Also, hearing you talk
about the financial crisis
is like this devastating
thing is so bizarre
cause I was just so young.
I was probably shitting myself
and watching Finding Nemo.
The thought of it having an impact.
- I mean, what, it was 2008, right.
I was 14.
- I was in a university.
- So I was probably 12 or something.
I'm 24.
- Oh my God.
Holy smoke Rooney.
(everyone laughing)
- Yeah I mean like.
- I think I was 11 then.
- Yeah. Cause I'd had
heard, like from my parents.
Being like, like you know,
damn the world got fucked over that.
- This is a big thing that's gonna happen.
And I'm just like,
I'm just trying to get
through my degree right now.
- I was probably what
were you eating Coco Pops
and you know, picking my nose.
- We gotta realize the same kind of thing
has happened now with COVID-19.
Four of us are very lucky
that we can still sit here employed.
- Absolutely.
- Cause a lot of people right now
in that position that I was in then
and they go on, oh God,
what am I going to do?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So the next generation of
Ladybeard is gonna come out.
- A couple of years from now.
They'll be like, 2.0 Ladybeard.
- With a pink mask.
- Yeah. So yeah. So that's
how it came to me, I guess.
- So, when did you move to Japan then?
- So then, I started doing
my metal covers of Cantonese pop songs.
And I started doing that in Hong Kong.
Very good.
Did a couple of tours
to some nearby places.
And I said, one of the
things that kind of gave me
the confidence to do it in the first place
because it's sort of,
when you go full time
as the cross-dresser,
you can't ever really go back, can you?
It's kind of, it works
or you're screwed. Right?
- Right, right, right.
- So one of the things that
kind of gave me the confidence
to do it was, well, if I
can't really get anything
going on in Hong Kong,
I know I can always move to Japan.
Cause I'm sure they'll
love something like this.
- Oh, yeah. Of course.
- So I did a tour to
Japan after I got myself
organized in Hong Kong.
Did Japanese songs.
So I couldn't speak Japanese yet.
Just learnt the songs phonetically.
- Oh, Wow.
- Put together a show.
- Came over here with the
handful of contacts I had
like three Japanese people I knew.
So I put together a show, but it popped.
Cause I was doing like covers
of metal covers of like
what's that girl who sings
First Love, Hikaru Shida?
No, that's, that's a wrestler.
- Utada Hikaru?
- Yeah. Thank you very much.
Doing it like metal covers
of that and so forth.
So the audience most, they
didn't know who I was.
- The audience wasn't
at any of these shows
would see this show.
They all knew the songs
cause they're famous songs.
- And they'd be the metal cover of course.
They're like, Ahh! this is hilarious.
So that too went incredibly well.
- So I'm like, okay
well clearly I found the chosen land.
The promised land.
As written in the ancient text.
The ancient promise land.
- The promise land of milk and honey.
- So I went back to Hong
Kong and I'm like, all right
clearly the mission now
needs to be moved to Japan.
And I did, and here we are.
- Wow.
- Do you know what it feels like?
You know, when you, like,
you put your headphones
in your pocket and it gets all tangled
and you have to like untangle it.
That's literally what we did
with your story right now.
It all finally fits together.
It all makes sense now.
- It's all finally one straight line
that I can understand.
- So I came over at the end of 2013.
And then the start of
2014, my images went viral
on the Twitter, the Twitter,
and then 2015 I was put in this pop group
with these two young singers
and we did a song called Nippon Manju.
And that blew up on the YouTubes.
And, now we're riding high.
- So, okay then like,
because I would say like
for people who don't know
Ladybeard for instance
I'd say like, I would say
though, like if there's one thing
about you that you've done in your career
that's probably, I would say it's probably
the most well-known would
probably be Ladybaby.
- Of course.
- So how did that come to be?
- So I was, it was me
and my former manager,
we're in Japan
we're only doing a stuff
in Japan and so forth.
And so I was on the cover
of Metropolis magazine.
Do you know that magazine?
- I've definitely heard of that.
- Yeah, it's a free magazine.
How can you guys be foreigners in Japan
and not know Metropolis?
- Leave my house, you
know what year it's been?
- Okay, fair enough.
It's a free English magazine,
like a street magazine in Tokyo.
I think in all Japan called Metropolis.
- Is there?
I've never seen it.
- I'm definitely afraid of
eye contact with strangers
holding things.
I'm like, don't, don't, no, no.
- Really? I thought you
Welshman loved a good fight.
- Give me the Metropolis magazine.
(everyone laughing)
I need my reads.
- If I love a good fight,
I think I'll be deported
very quickly.
- So there's this magazine.
- Wow it's a very popular
magazine amongst every foreigner
in Japan except one, two, three.
- Meilyne, did you know about this?
- Yeah, right?
- Meilyne has lived here for ages.
- Ashley did you know about this?
- [Ashley] No.
- Yes, right?
There are five foreigners here,
who didn't know about it.
- My friends who work
at Metropolis magazine
I sincerely apologize
for this negative press
that you are currently receiving
on the Trash Taste podcast.
- Clearly the marketing
strategy needs to be redone.
I'm just you know.
- Dude, that magazine is everywhere.
- Clearly not everywhere.
- Where do you get it?
Like convenience store or?
- If you, no. Not the convenience store.
But if you go to Tower Records or whatnot,
they got their stack of free magazines.
- I don't think I've
been to a Tower Records
in about a year.
- Wait, You look at the
free stack of magazines?
I just see potential toilet roll.
- When you get to the airport
and your you're walking from
your plane to immigration.
There's always magazines and stuff.
- I'm just checking my phone.
- Yeah, you're just
checking your phone, right?
I guess.
- Young people! Bloody generation gap!
- Millennials.
Okay, so you're on, you're on the cover.
- Anyway, I'm on the cover
of Metropolis magazine.
The CEO of a Halloween costume company
is getting off a plane,
he's walking through the airport.
And he sees metropolis
magazine with me on it.
It's me and my pink and
white bikini, flexing.
And he said, what the hell is that?
(everyone laughing)
- He stops at the airport,
in front of everybody.
- He's actually Chinese.
So probably said,
(speaking in foreign language)
it was probably what he actually said.
(everyone laughing)
- I just love to imagine
like, just this like
super proper CEO, just like
minding his own business,
bluetooth headphone in his ear.
And he's just like, the fuck is that?!
- So he takes the magazine.
And he takes it back to his office.
And he's just like, look at this!
And his staff were like,
yeah, that's this Ladybeard guy.
It's this foreigner dude.
And he said, bring him in.
I want to work with him, bring him in.
- Wow.
- So we get a contact from this company
and we go in and he's like,
I want to work with you.
I'm like, all right.
I thought he was,
it's Halloween costume company, right?
So I thought he's gonna make
like a line of my bikinis
to sell in Halloween.
He's like, I want to work with
you, but I don't know how.
So, we'll be in touch.
- Okay.
- Like okay.
- So he put you to his office to say that?
- Yeah, we go back to what we were doing.
And a month later he calls us in again
and he's like, I'm going
to put you in a pop group
with our pair of idols.
- Wow.
Wait, wait, how did that happen?
- That's another jump.
- How did he come up with that idea?
- Well I wasn't there for that.
- Okay, okay.
- You know, cause he did that
in the privacy of his own space.
- Your life just sounds
like a roulette wheel.
What is going on?
What is the structure?
- That's what you get
for waking up in Vegas.
- Yeah, it's just like,
here's a bunch of money.
It's like, Oh, I don't even
remember betting on black.
Anyway. So, okay.
So, so this guy somehow
manages to get you in
this idol group.
- Yeah. So he spoke to
some people he knew.
And he's, I'm gonna put you in a group.
And then we did that
first song and it blew up.
- And that was Ladybaby.
Wow.
So he somehow knew Babymetal?
Wait, what?
Babymetal? Were they
even establish back then?
- Yeah, they were, they were
very popular at the time.
It was recently after Gimme chocolate.
So they were very hot
and they were getting
spoken about a lot in Japan.
But it's like, I remember the meeting
he goes
he goes, yeah, cause
he's a heavy metal singer
and they're idols.
Yeah. Yeah.
So your Babymetal.
Are very popular at the moment, are they?
Yeah.
So be just like Babymetal
but with Ladybeard.
Ladybeard.
Babymetal.
Ladybaby. That was the meeting.
I'm I right?
- Cool.
I guess.
- And this was the CEO
of a Halloween costume?
- Halloween costume.
- And they just decided to get into.
- This how people see CEO, Garnt.
They're fast thinking, like that.
It's the kind of fast thinking we need
as far as CEO does.
- That's a decision-making
skills right there.
- He's a smart man.
He's from China.
He came over to Japan like with no money,
like 30 years ago or something.
And he made his living like,
he'd go outside Tokyo Dome,
this was during the bubble,
outside Tokyo dome, he would like sell,
like light sticks or something
when there was sporting events.
And he somehow made his business happen.
- That is literally how like
every entrepreneur in
the seventies started.
Isn't that like every entrepreneur
story from the seventies?
It's like, I had no money
when coming to this country.
- Started on the streets
and now we're here.
- I sold paper clips and now I own
a multi-million dollar corporation.
- He did a good job.
- Man, my dad was rich.
- Gave me a small loan
of a million dollars.
- This episode is sponsored by Harry's.
- You know what you shouldn't have
to choose between, gentlemen?
- [Joey] What?
- A great shave and a fair price.
- I'm always trying to
choose between the two.
And frankly, I'm quite sick of it.
- That's where you're wrong, Joey.
Cause with Harry's you won't have to.
- Oh my God.
- And as you guys know last
time when we promoted Harry's
they gave us the box to promote
and I actually took it home and used it.
And gentlemen,
- Was it good?
- It's fucking good.
- Really?
- It's good.
- I mean, you are the hairiest
member of Trash Taste.
- I know, I know I'm always
shaving here and it was, yeah
it was so clean much better than ones
that I get from the store.
I know that sounds like an ad.
Like I'm being told to
that, but it's legit.
That's a hundred percent.
It's good, it's good.
- [Garnt] Harry's delivers
a close comfortable shave
at a fair price.
Still as low as $2 per refill.
That's actually really fucking good.
- [Joey] And for a limited time,
Harry's is offering their starter set
plus a free travel size bodywash
at harrys.com/trashtaste.
- As you guys know, from all
previous Harry's sponsorship,
they have their own German factory
that makes blades to a precision.
They've been doing it
for over a hundred years
to give you that clean shave.
- That's why you fucking love it right?
- That's why I love it.
And there's no gimmicks
or unnecessary features.
It's just a damn good razor.
Combined with a weighted handle
and ergonomic texture grip and flex hinge.
I don't even know what
most of these words mean
but all I know is that
it was a damn good shave.
- It sounds clean as fuck.
Plus there is a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed.
Harry's stands behind the
quality of their blade so much
that they have a 100% money back guarantee
on harrys.com.
- And the prices are pretty damn fair.
Just like Garnt said, $2 a refill.
- I mean, we've already
talked about the price.
That's pretty damn good in my opinion.
So what are you waiting for?
For a limited time Harry's
has made their exclusive offer
even better for listeners of this show.
New customers can get the special offer
and the Harry's starter set and body wash
at harrys.com/trashtaste.
- [Connor] And if you go there,
you'll get a five blade razor,
weighted Truman handle, foaming shave gel,
a travel blade cover, and
a travel size body wash.
And it's pretty damn good by the way.
There's never been a
time to go to Harry's.
So go to harrys.com/trashtaste
to redeem your offer today.
- Thank you to Harry's
for sponsoring episode.
Back to the show.
- Hi gentlemen, I'm gonna bring us back in
from the commercial break.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna to do it as if,
as if, we're in South Africa
I'm going to do it in an Afrikaans accent.
- Why South Africa?
- POV, you're at South Africa.
- I'll tell ya, I'll
tell ya why in a second.
Let me just bring us back
from this commercial break.
Ready?
- Okay.
I'm gonna do it like it's my show.
- South Africans, rate, rate this accent.
You ready? Here we go.
Welcome back to the Trash Taste podcast.
On the voice of Africa radio network.
I'm your host Ladybeard,
here today with my guests,
Connor, Garnt and Joey.
Gentlemen, how are you?
- That's actually a really good.
- Thanks man.
I've got a thing for South
Africa at the moment.
- You sound, you sound
like my math teacher
back in high school.
- Was he South African?
- He was very South African.
- Okay, cool. Excellent, thank you.
- Have you ever view, no
he's not South African.
- If any Africano were
offended by my accent
I was not trying to
appropriate your culture.
I'll let you know.
(everyone laughing)
- What is happening?
- I'll let you know.
I have.
So my shower curtain.
(everyone bursting out laughing)
- What is going on? What
is actually going on?
- Stop interrupting Thai elephant God.
I'll tell you what's going on.
- You know what this is like?
This is the conversation equivalent
of like changing tabs.
- We have been like
completely drunk for episodes
that were easier to follow than this.
What is going on?
- Ladybeard shower curtain.
- Okay.
Okay, talk about you shower curtain.
- Is a very badly
produced map of the world.
- Okay.
So when I was buying shower curtains
from whichever shower curtain
dispensary I was buying from.
- Right.
- Probably wasn't Amazon
cause I'm too old.
So, I bought the cheapest one
and it was this very poorly
produced map of the world.
- Okay.
- And like, it's like the
borders are in the wrong places.
The colors of the countries
bleed over the borders.
Things are spelled wrong.
And one of the things it does
is on a country,
it does not highlight the
biggest city or the capital city.
It highlights some other city.
- Just some random cities.
- And then, the other cities are left out.
So for instance, in Australia,
think in Australia they
managed to get Canberra.
So that was, that was right.
- At least they got the capital.
- Yeah.
In Japan, Sendai
and no other city.
- Right.
- And then, so then, all right.
- So how does that lead
to Afrikaans accent?
This connection I wanna see.
- When I'm sitting on the toilet
and I won't go into detail
about what's going on at the time.
- Well, we can imagine.
- You can imagine this.
My eye line is such that I looked directly
at that bottom part of Africa on this map.
So it's like South
Africa, Namibia, Botswana.
- Right, right, right.
- And on the South Africa,
because it's a dodgy map,
there's no Cape Town.
There's no Johannesburg,
but there is Bloemfontein.
(both chuckling)
- Okay. Which is just some random town.
- Bloemfontein, is
personally, it's fun to say.
(both laughing)
Say it with me, you try.
- What is it?
- Bloemfontein.
- Bloemfontein?
- That was excellent.
Can you say that in a Welsh accent?
(everyone laughing)
- You know what that sounds like?
That sounds like
something the Swedish chef
will sound on the Muppets.
Bloemfontein.
(speaking gibberish)
- And this is a real place?
- It's a real place. It's the capital.
- Four fucking privileged people laughing
at African town names.
- It's the capital of
a part of South Africa
called Free State.
- Okay.
- Bloemfontein.
- Is the capital of that.
- Biggest city slash
capital of Free State.
And that's.
- Everyone who's watching
this from Bloemfontein
is like, why it's so funny?
- And Bloemfontein is what I look at
when I'm sitting on the toilet.
- Taking a shit.
- And, so for that reason
I did some research on Bloemfontein.
- Okay.
- And now my current,
my boom is South Africa.
So.
- So that's why you did
the Afrikaans accent?
- It's why I did the Afrikaans accent.
And you can call me, I don't
know a Africana surname.
What's a common Africana surname?
- You're asking as if I know.
- (indistinct)
You can call me Ladybeard (indistinct)
from here on in.
Joey, take it away.
- I don't, I don't think
I can take it away.
- We we're on the Ladybaby, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was about to bring us back though.
- You guys from now on
can never give a shit
for the amount of tangents we go on.
Cause that was easily the biggest tangent
we've ever been on.
- I was about to say,
we're quite famous for going on tangents.
And I swear there's like
tangents within tangents
within tangents.
Like when you tell a single story.
- That was like,
that was like moving
into a different shape.
- No tangent has ever been
started as beautifully
as my shower curtain.
It's the greatest start to a tangent.
- What a great way to start a tangent.
- Okay, so Ladybaby.
- So a Halloween costumes CEO
put me in a pop group.
- Ladybaby.
- And you were in Ladybaby.
And how long did that go for?
- Well, I was in Ladybaby,
so our first ever song Nippon Manju
blew up on the internet.
And it got very, very popular.
And so now we were the
hottest group of 2015.
- And so when this was formed,
You had, you didn't have, say
who were the two idols were?
It's literally, we're
putting you with two people.
Be friends with them.
- Yeah, that's right.
- Okay.
- So that happened.
I was in Ladybaby for like
a year and a half or something.
So I did like four singles with them.
And then some other kind of
B-side type songs as well.
Due to a series of events I won't go into,
I was unceremoniously relieved
of my position in Ladybaby.
- Right.
- And now they don't exist anymore.
- Was it because you,
at the Denny's being a little too?
- A bit too noisy?
- Bit too noisy.
- Did you get a noise complaint?
- Every time I was at Denny's. Every time.
You know what, yeah.
It turns out when you
choose a heavy metal singer,
you want him to be as quiet as a mouse.
Anyway-
- So then, yeah.
So then you did the Ladybaby stuff
and then you kind of did a
whole other bunch of groups.
- Did a bunch of other stuff,
my time in that group ended.
They went on without me, but
now they're done anyways.
So that whole thing has come to an end.
I went and did some other stuff.
But now.
- You have a new group.
- Finally.
Got a new group.
So everyone loved Ladybaby
when I was there, right?
So me and the two cute
little Japanese girls
everyone loved it.
I'm like, let's do that again.
And for a series of reasons,
we couldn't for five years.
- Right.
- Basically sum it up,
Japanese showbiz politics. Basically.
We did some other stuff.
I have been happy with
the other stuff I've done.
But now we're in a position
where we can do it again.
So I'm like, sweet.
Let's do it again.
So basically what we've
done is we've constructed
as many of the parts that came together
to make Nippon Manju as we could.
We've reconstructed those.
And we're doing the same thing again.
And it's, I'm very excited
because for five years
I've been every day been told,
why did you leave Ladybaby?
I wanted you to keep doing it, I liked it.
Every day for five years.
So finally I can do this formation again
cause clearly it's what I want to do.
It's what the whole world wants to see.
So, brace yourselves,
ladies and gentlemen,
Ladybeard 2021 coming at
you with brand new group.
I'm allowed to release brand
new group's name. Correct?
- [Woman in the background] Yes.
(everyone laughing)
- Wait, what's the name?
- Babybeard.
Ohh! Ohh!
(Joey and Garnt clapping)
2021 ladies and gentlemen. Babybeard.
Coming at you.
- PPV.
- Babybeard.
- That makes more sense than Ladybaby.
- It does. It does.
- Like, like as a name. right?
- I thought that,
at that naming meeting, I was like,
(Ladybeard whispering)
- Why not Babybeard? Yeah.
- If you're going to take that approach.
No, no, no.
- Ladybaby.
- Okay.
Okay, Let's ignore the one person
in the room who speaks English.
Here's idea of a good English name.
So Babybeard is unlike Donkey Kong.
I'm so excited.
- Have you done stuff with them yet?
(everyone laughing)
- I don't know if I said a
good thing or a bad thing.
- No. We've done nothing, Joey.
- I'll have you know,
we haven't done shit.
- Incidentally, it's funny you asked that.
- Yes.
- Because this whole
thing was ready to get up
and get running at the beginning of 2020.
- Right.
Well we all know what happened to that.
- We all know what happened to that.
So now we're in this unique position
where we have a new group to release
and we're not really capable of doing
all the things you normally
you do to release a group.
- Right. You're kind of stuck in limbo.
- So, what you need to do
is you need to head down
to the Babybeard TikTok.
There you're gonna see all the latest
from Babybeard coming at you
full of updates and all the
things we're gonna be doing.
As soon as we're allowed
to do normal things
like be on a stage.
- I love how, like this
is the first guests
that we've had that's just like,
fuck the end of the show.
I'll promote my shit now.
- Hell yeah I am.
Oy, oy, oy. Hey!
- You're a true showman.
- Hey, hey, hey.
Go to social media.
Look up Babybeard.
- Do the thing.
- The ticky tocky. The twitty twatty.
I shouldn't say that word.
The twitty twappy.
The facie bookie.
The instant ham.
Do we have another one
that I'm forgetting about?
- Well we'll put all the
links in the description.
- In the description.
Smash the like button.
That's what the young people say nowadays.
- But they don't say it in
the middle of the episode.
They say that at the end.
- This podcast is just starting guys.
- What, what, where am I?
- We're still going, we're still going.
- Welcome back to the Trash Taste podcast.
This the part of the voice
of Africa radio network.
- We can't just welcome back every time.
We will be welcoming back-
- Every five minutes.
We'll welcome them back.
- Every toilet break, welcome back.
- Anyway, I have a new
group called Babybeard.
Me, two adorable Japanese girls.
It's gonna be fantastic.
If you love to Nippon
Manju, you will love this.
Go watch it please.
Oh!
- I'm just, I'm just glad your-
- The table is the victim today.
You're fucking beating the shit out.
- That's what happens when
you bring a pro wrestler in.
Joey's gonna get body-slammed
through this in a second.
- Great.
- It's a great table actually.
- I'm just glad you're sticking
with something familiar for once.
Not going to like fucking astrophysics
or something like that.
- I don't know much about it.
- No, no, don't, don't.
It's fine, it's fine.
- So, I'm curious when you
made your previous group
you've you said that you
didn't even have a say in it.
Did you get much say when
you're making this one
like who you wanted to bring
on to it or was it literally
just find me two cute Japanese girls?
- We held auditions.
- Oh okay.
- And you got to choose?
- Yup. So I was on the audition panel.
Tell you what
auditioning was a totally different thing.
As in, being on the choosing
side of the audition.
Cause for my whole life, I've been on the,
doing the auditions.
- It's the first time
I'd been on the, you know
watching the audition side,
it's a different game.
But instantly, it's very interesting
cause it kind of takes away any,
it means that all the times
you've been rejected in auditions.
It no longer feels personal.
- No, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Once you're a panel.
Cause you can see,
girls came in and they were wonderful.
Like they were really good.
I was like, I think you're fantastic
but you're just not what
we need right now for this.
Couple of them, really good.
But just like a bit too tall,
things like this, right?
- Right, right, right.
- But it's kind of upsetting.
Cause you're like, I
want to give you a job,
but I just can't.
- Right, right.
- So what were you looking for?
What was the criteria?
- Not too tall.
- That was the main criteria.
Not too tall.
Nah, that's it.
- Really?
- No, no.
- I was going to say
there's plenty of grandma's
here to would be perfect.
- So were are you like looking
for like a certain like vocal style?
Cause I assume it's like vocalist, right?
- Yeah but they had to be able to sing.
They need to be able to dance.
They had to be small enough.
They had to be cute enough.
They had to be willing-
- Just a normal idol.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but they had to be
willing to go all over the world.
Cause you know
when there's no fricking
bloody death flu apocalypse.
We're planning to be
going all over the world.
- How did you make it
sound worse than it is.
- Death flu apocalypse?
- Death flu apocalypse, that's a great.
Death flu apocalypse is like
an amazing metal band name.
- Death flu apocalypse. Dadadada.
- That's what you should call Babybeard.
- Maybe I should.
- Yeah, death flu apocalypse.
- That's our second single,
death flu apocalypse.
That's actually a really good idea.
Shiori make a note please.
Death flu apocalypse.
I can't remember what we're saying.
- The criteria for the auditions.
- Yes, the auditions.
- But it's like yeah, you had
to be willing to go overseas.
And they were the main criteria.
And then it's also standing with me
and the other two.
Does that piece, fits the puzzle?
A lot of them it's like,
you're really good.
We really like you, but you
don't fit together with me.
And any of the other girls.
So it's a bit hard, we
had to get two of them.
- Right. Right.
- One is relatively easy.
Two is hard.
- Right.
- So you need two people
who can match this up.
Anyway, we did.
We ended up with two fantastic girls
one called Kotomi and one called Suzu.
And foreigners always thinks
Suzu's name is either Susan
or Suza.
- Susan.
- It's neither of those two.
Think Suzuki, without the ki.
- No, you should just
commit to the Susan bit.
- Susan.
- That should be like her nickname.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- She's not a librarian.
- Is every Susan a librarian?
- Maybe they are.
- I don't know a single
Susan, so I couldn't tell you.
- You don't know a single Susan?
I know some Susans.
- You know a single Susan?
- No.
- Suddenly a single Susan
cannot be established in this.
- All the Susan's in the comment section,
raise your hand right now.
- I'm a Susan.
- I am a big fan of Susans everywhere.
(all laughing)
Susans are wonderful people.
Susan, Susan I love you. I'm
not trying to offend you.
The point I'm trying to make
is Suzu is not named Susan.
That's the point.
- Yeah but you made it
sounded like as if like
I love everyone named Susan,
but these other names.
Yikes.
- Oh, I'm knackered.
- You're knackered?
- I'm getting tired just like.
- I gotta drink some of my fluids.
- So like, okay.
So I guess like.
- Where do you even
begin asking questions?
- Yeah, right? Cause it's like.
- This shit is so crazy.
It's like what the fuck.
- Where do we even start?
- We have got the same
musicians who made Nippon Manju.
- Okay.
- And they have made a
banger of the first single.
- So Nippon Manju is the famous?
- That was the first, that was the-
- It was a famous Ladybaby song.
- Can I say the name of first single?
- [Woman in the background]
Dozo. (go ahead)
- Oh! Please.
Go to internet check out
NIPPON KARA KONNICHIWA
by Babybeard.
Same people who made Nippon Manju,
it's amazing people.
It's a piece of musical madness.
It'll make your earbuds
tingle with wonder.
You have never heard
something as amazing as this.
Adorable Japanese cute idol voices.
One noisy cross-dresser screaming.
What more could you want
in a musical product?
Joey, take us to a commercial.
- Our audio reader looks insane right now.
- You just destroyed that microphone.
- Why are we reading the ads?
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- I don't want to read the ads.
- Let me read the ads. What's the product?
What's the product we're advertising?
- You just read your own ad.
- You literally just read-
- You didn't even need talking points.
- Yeah. You are the talking points.
- Let's do an ad for a fake product
that we haven't invented yet.
Like a South African survival kit.
You ready?
- Shitty shower curtains.
- Well I don't know about you
but when I found myself
lost in Bloemfontein,
It's always important to make sure
that I've got a survival kit with me.
This way, if I find myself without food,
water or shelter,
there'll be something I'll be able to do.
- You make it sound like
that town is like the woods.
- Is this a fever dream?
Like I, what have I stumbled into today?
- I've had fever dreams that
are less weird than this.
- I hope, I hope there are no
South African ladies named Susan,
who happens to listen to this.
If you're a South African named Susan
leave a message in the comment box below.
- Okay.
- I'm curious.
So you, you know, you,
obviously you said that
you're gonna be touring worldwide.
- Yeah.
- Where is the majority of
your audience? Japanese?
- So well obviously Japan, but you know,
it's just the group, you know,
we have the death flu
apocalypse at the moment.
It's a little bit hard
to establish physically.
Where the audience is gonna be.
Personally I have a big fan
bases all over the world.
Which is great.
So we went to the conventions,
like you characters do.
- Characters.
(everyone laughing)
- Do you not consider
yourself a character?
Thai elephant God.
- I mean the first time
I met you was, yeah.
That was, oh God, how
many years ago was that?
- That was 2016.
- Five years ago?
- 16. Yeah, 2016. Five years ago.
And like I had known about you.
But then when I actually saw you in person
I was like, oh shit.
- Oh, thank you.
- It's that guy in the dress.
- I feel like, you know, I
don't know if this is rude
but I feel like a lot
of people know of you,
but they're not like quite sure, you know.
Cause, cause when you know.
- Your reputation proceeds you.
- You're just a memorable character.
- Listen, If I pop up in
your feed right, you know?
On Twitter you see my face
like, great, another white guy.
You know, you see you, it's
kinda hard not to be like,
I think I've seen this
before. You know what I mean?
I feel like that happens a lot.
- It's either,
I've never seen this or
I've definitely seen this.
- You know you've seen it, you know.
- You might hit it with
the, what the hell is that?
- I have people watch my videos.
Tons of them.
They'll be like, they'll talk to me like,
do I know you? From somewhere?
Yeah I'm every white, generic,
white guy in existence.
- No, you look beautiful.
- Have you ever had anyone
come up to you and being like
have you, dead ass ever
came up to you and be like,
have I seen you before?
- All the time.
- Really?
- It's much more like, Oh lady beard.
That's much more what's it's like.
- Right, right but I'm talking about like,
people are like, they're not
sure if you're Ladybeard.
- Yes.
Yes.
- Really?
- Yes.
But what's-
- Because your so like-
- What's interesting of being,
about being a long-haired
bearded white man in Japan,
is there's quite a lot of
long-haired beard white man in Japan.
- Really?
- And I have been confused
with people such as Zakk Wylde.
- Who?
- Who's Zakk Wylde?
- He plays guitar for Black Sabbath.
And Black Label Society.
He's a metal heavy metal legend.
I don't look like him.
But I've got long hair
and a beard so I do.
- It's like, white, long haired,
beard. You're Zakk Wylde.
- You can see the picture right here.
- It looks nothing alike.
- I was standing at a bus stop in Shibuya,
I'm standing there waiting my bus stop.
And this lady actually,
she was another white lady.
I shouldn't say another one.
Cause this is the first one at the story.
Apart from South African Susan.
She was a white lady,
she comes up and she
looks at the bus stop,
she reads the time, and
she sort of looks at me.
Reads the times. Looks at
her phone and she goes,
you look like Jesus.
- Bearded man with long hair.
- You look like Jesus.
I like, ah, thank you.
She goes, can you do this?
I want to take a photo
and send it to my kids.
- What?
- I'm like,
okay. So I did this.
(everyone laughing)
- Why her kids?
- Yeah.
- Look at what I made this
peasant do at the taxi stand.
I made him T-pose.
- I'm an atheist, but I
know you guys love Jesus.
- Oy, oy, I think as far
as people to look like,
Jesus is pretty good.
- I mean I got that before as well.
- You got Jesus?
- when I had long hair.
- Japanese Jesus?
- Yeah. Japanese Jesus, yeah.
- I feel like anyone with like long hair,
and a slight beard.
I'm sure they got that comment before.
- And is tall.
- You'll be Thai Jesus.
- It's literally, it's literally,
it's literally long hair,
beard and you're tall. Right?
That's the three steps to be Jesus.
- Three steps to be Jesus.
Long hair, beard and you're tall.
- Where's the wikiHow article like on how.
- How to be Jesus.
(everyone laughing)
- I've never, have you ever
had like crazy requests
like that from fans in the street?
Like to be like, can
you do this weird thing?
- I've never asked to do T-pose before.
- No, I've never asked the T-pose either.
- I will pretty well do now.
- Yeah.
- It's good.
I'm like T-T ahh. It's like T-T ahh.
- Is there any like, I guess, okay.
- That felt flat didn't it?
- No, I was just trying to
like formulate my question.
- There's so many things going on.
I'm trying to make sense
of this chaos right now.
- Sensory overload from one course.
- Okay. So cause like, I would say like,
I think anyone can agree. Right?
Looking at your entire history,
you have done a lot of fucking things.
You've done a lot of different things.
Is there like anything,
that is a total understatement.
But like, is there anything
that you would personally like,
to like kind of add onto that?
Is there like another
completely separate thing,
where you're like,
maybe down the road I'd like
to do something like that.
- I've injured myself now.
(Ladybeard coughing)
I want to do fricking Babybeard.
As in my time with Ladybaby
was brought to a halt so
prematurely and so abruptly.
And I'm not going to go into details.
But look I was not really treated
very nicely in the process.
- [Garnt] Right.
- And that was so unfinished.
That I feel a sense of incompletion.
If we don't go back and we
don't finish that cycle off now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So that's kind of what I wanted to do.
Be there. Then beyond that
there's many other things
that I want to do.
- That are like completely
separate, right?
From what you want to do.
- Yeah. But I don't want
to bring 'em up now.
- Oh yeah. I mean, I guess you gotta,
you gotta, you gotta hide it right.
And kind of reveal it or?
- Look yeah look, Joey.
Or you just don't want to share it?
- I do.
- If you say it now,
there's pressure to do it.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- No it's not that.
Look, let's just stick with one thing
we're talking about at one time.
So far we've been very unsuccessful
doing that for the rest of the podcast.
- We've been unsuccessful
because you go in 17 million tangents.
- That was one accent that
turned into a different accent
halfway through.
Ay, look, I just want to do Babybeard.
That other thing I feel
like I'll do it with another
hour within my life.
When we finish that, I do another thing.
All righty now?
And that's the thing.
Mama Mia.
- What. Where do we go from here?
How did we get here?
- I'm like genuinely like,
I've never been dumbfounded in my life.
- Can I ask a question?
- Sure.
- Please.
- Garnt?
- Yes?
- Your individual YouTube channel.
- Yes.
- How do you pronounce the name of that?
- Gigguk.
Did you pronounce the gig
UK? Like everyone else?
- I said guy gook.
(everyone laughing)
- That's the third alternative.
- And then, and then I
thought potentially GG UK.
I thought maybe you were
just a huge Girls' Generation fan.
♪ G,G,G,G, baby, baby ♪
♪ G,G,G ♪
Let's sing Girls' Generation.
- We're gonna get copyright claimed.
- Ahh. Ahh.
- Oh really? Copyright claim? What?
- Because you're just,
you're just too good.
- Acapella? You can't do an acapella?
- No, no, no.
- Get out of here.
You can't sing any song?
- No.
- Get outta here.
- Ladybeard discovers
the YouTube algorithm.
- You've been spoiled by TikTok.
- Yeah.
So the YouTube algorithm
has gotten so good now
that they can detect covers of songs.
When people are just singing it.
- What if you're trying to sing the song
but you're a really bad singer?
- No.
- Get outta here.
- I've heard people like,
I've actually heard stories
of people humming songs
in their YouTube videos
and getting copyright claims for it.
- Get outta here.
What if you make an original song
and purely by chance
you accidentally picked
the same, as the real song?
- That's called a lawsuit.
- No, seriously. You'll lose that.
- Yeah. You'll lose that.
- Welcome to the YouTube ecosystem.
- Man discovers YouTube algorithm.
It's terrible.
- This is the first time on the podcast
where I'm seeing you, just
be dumbfounded for words.
- It's so bizarre cause
I live in a universe
where I feel like pretend
like music doesn't exist
outside of copyright free
music. It's so bizarre.
- Is there any questions
you'd like to ask us?
Cause I feel like we've
asked like literally
every question we can ask you.
- It's been good.
I feel a bit selfish for not
talking a bit about you people.
- No, no, no.
You're the guest.
- Our viewers know us,
they're probably sick of us.
- I was really enthusiastic
to hear about Gigguk slash GG UK.
So now that that's done
I want to sing Girls'
Generation with everybody.
- I'm curious. Have you
ever had a normal job?
Like quote unquote normal.
I'm just wondering.
Because I'm sitting here thinking, right,
you know, if I went into like
I go into like H&M or
you're just there like,
how is your t-shirt sir?
- I can't imagine you at like a BIG W
or anything like that.
I can't imagine you're
at like a regular store.
- One of the reasons I've
worked so hard on this career
is exactly because I don't
exactly fit in elsewhere.
- Have you ever had a normal job?
- Yes, I guess my first jobs were normal.
- What were your first jobs?
- I want to hear stories .
- I worked in retail.
Like when I was 18 or whatever.
- What did you do?
- You know the store in Australia,
girls clothing store called Supré?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I worked at Supré.
- You've worked at a Supré?
- I was the first boy they ever hired.
- Yeah.
- How did that go?
- Now I'm wearing the stock.
- Did they fire you just
from grabbing the stock?
- Where do you think learned to drip from?
- I'm very bad at normal jobs.
This is why I've got such a-
- I cannot imagine you
working at a retail at all.
- I wasn't very good at it.
So I worked retail and then
I didn't enjoy it much.
So I stopped that
and then I became a dish
pig in a restaurant.
So I was a dish pig
in like the nicest restaurant in Adelaide.
- Oh, wow.
- So one way, that's a great-
- The finest establishment.
- Welcome to South Australia.
- We have one McDonald's.
- Yeah. So I was a dish
pig on this restaurant
which was actually,
actually quite a good job.
There were a few things
about it that made it hard.
I was bad at the plates.
As in, I was good at doing the pans,
scrubbing the fry pads of that.
I liked that I was good at it.
I was very slow at the plates
and the knives and forks.
So that ruined it for me.
- Because it's like more like fragile or?
- I was just bad at it.
Well it depends you've got,
you're there with your sink
Pan goes, sorry.
Pan goes in, wash pan.
Pan goes out.
With the plates and stuff.
There was like an industrial dishwasher
that you had to load.
So you gotta get the plates loaded
put them in, wash them, get
them out, get them dried.
- Wouldn't that be easier though?
- Well, I was just bad
at it. I don't know why.
- How do you be bad at that?
- I was just bad at it.
- Cause like dishes are more delicate
and I can't imagined you
handling things delicately.
- That's part of it.
But also it's just this
just such volume of it.
You've got to go so fast.
So that's what I felt. I could do it,
but I was just slow.
So therefore I could not
work if it was only me
I had to be there with someone else
and I would do the pans and
they would do the machine.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
But generally I actually
quite enjoyed that job.
The problem is it was always
on a Friday and Saturday night.
So you'd miss your social life, right?
No more cross dressing
parties for me, Garnt.
I was covered in slop.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
- [Connor] We all shop
online and gentlemen
we've all seen that promo
code field taunt us.
It keeps me up at night.
- It, I can't stand it.
- Thanks to Honey,
manually searching for coupon codes
like a peasant is a thing of the past.
- Tell me, Joey, what does Honey do?
- Honey is the free shopping
tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies
the best ones it finds to your cart.
It supports over 30,000 stores online.
- 30,000?
- 30,000.
And they range from sites that
have tech and gaming products
to popular fashion brands
and even food delivery.
- I've saved over $30 on pizza
and we all know how expensive
that damn thing is in Japan.
But thankfully, thanks to Honey.
It's an affordable price.
But Garnt, how does it work?
- I'll tell you how it works, Connor.
Imagine this, you're shopping
on one of your favorite sites.
- I'm imagining.
- So when you're at the checkout,
the Honey button drops down
and all you have to do
is click apply coupons,
wait a few seconds
and then Honey will
search for all the coupons
it can find and apply it to that site.
- [Joey] It's that easy?
- Yes. And if Honey finds a working coupon
you just watch as the price goes down.
- What?
- Damn.
- Not just that Garnt,
Honey has found it's
over 17 million members
over $2 billion in savings.
- B, billion with a B?
- That's B, Garnt.
- Wow.
- [Joey] If You don't already have Honey
you could be straight up
missing out on free savings.
It's literally free and
installs in just a few seconds.
- [Connor] And by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid
and supporting this podcast
and we would never recommend
something we don't use.
- So, you can get honey for free
at joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste
links are down in description below.
- Back to the episode.
- Meilyne's killing it.
Let's hear it for Meilyne.
Meilyne and Ashley, killing it.
Meilyne, Ashley and Shiori
doing an excellent job.
Okay.
I quite enjoy long flights.
- To the audience you just went,
- How can anyone enjoy long flights?
What'd you enjoy?
Are you in like, economy?
- When you're running around all the time.
- What Meilyne?
- Are you a peasant?
- That did sound a bit
aggressive Thai elephant God.
- No, no.
- You don't fly in economy do you?
- Riffraff exit my studio.
Caviar please.
- No, because in my mind I don't enjoy,
like I only fly economy and
I don't enjoy that shit.
- Yeah like I feel like when
you said, I enjoyed flights.
- He's backpedaling, trying to
appeal to the little people.
- If someone says I enjoy flying
my first immediate thought
is ah, Emirates first class.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly. Yeah.
- My stance on the experience.
(everyone laughing)
My stance on the experience is you know,
being the people we are, show business.
Busy schedules, busy lives.
Lots of getting up and
running around the place.
Tokyo trains, hectic, hectic, hectic.
Get to the airplane.
No choice, but to just sit there.
For nine hours.
- [Connor] That's great.
- And watch a damn movie.
- Right, right.
So what's crazy about that?
- Because it means I'm not
running around like a psychopath.
- No, I do agree that it's quite relaxing
cause this is like the
one time that you like
disconnect from the world.
- Yeah.
- Cause there's no other option.
No one can get upset if
you didn't reply an email
cause you're on a plane.
- That's true.
- Actually, since they started
introducing WiFi to planes,
I actually don't like it.
- No, cause the worst part is
that it's not even good enough.
So it's just good enough where
you can maybe load a tweet
after refreshing like ten times.
So you get your hope up.
You pay 20 bucks for it and it's shit.
- No, no.
I completely get like the
whole like disconnecting from
the internet thing.
Because like I remember like one time
I flew the one time I
flew business in my life,
I was like, Oh I get WiFi.
And it's fast enough to load YouTube.
Hell yeah.
All I'm going to do is watch YouTube.
In the end I slept for half of it.
- It's very comfortable in business.
- That's the point right?
People get to sleep.
- Right, right.
But I was like, Oh no
I'm going to be in the
most comfortable position
watching all the YouTube I want.
And there'll be no
distractions whatsoever.
I think I watched it for like two hours
and I was like, I'm gonna sleep.
- I don't know what it is about plane but
for me sleeping on a plane
is like nearby impossible.
Like there's just like they,
I can't know how you
sleep with your physique.
I have trouble finding
enough space on like
on like a plane seat as it is.
- You must scare everyone
when you walk on that plane.
Everyone's like, fuck, please
I hope he's not next to me.
- Think I'm a terrorist or something.
With my beard and my long ass hair.
- No. You're just like a giant dude.
- If I see someone, I'm not gonna lie
if I'm sitting there in economy right.
I see you walking down the aisle.
I'm like, please, please.
Not next to me. Not next to me.
Cause I'm like, I like
it when it's an old lady.
Cause I know she's gonna be like tiny.
- If there's a massive dude of this size
sitting next to you
like, well, rip armrest.
That armrest is going to him not me.
- And the moment I ask you
to move, to go to the toilet.
I've made like a fucking scene.
It's like the whole plane is to reshuffle
when you're getting up.
- Chickens are falling out.
Next time you catch a plane,
you could try reading a book.
(everyone laughing)
- Sarcasm, I assume?
- No I'm serious.
So another thing you could do at a plane-
- That's what I do though.
It gives me a plenty of
time to like read a book.
- This sounds like, you know
one of those very pandering things like,
10 things you can do on a plane.
- Read a book.
Have you ever heard of
one of those before?
- Life hacks, 10 things
you can do on a plane.
- Books contain a wealth of knowledge
you can access during your
nine hours of sitting.
- Do you read a lot of books?
- I do now.
I never did before.
But it was about halfway through 2019.
I suddenly became a bookaholic.
- Why?
- Oh, I dunno. Something snapped.
Well, I was doing a lots of
shows in China at the time.
And so I was back and forth,
back and forth, back and forth.
It's funny cause everyone on
the management team is like
why it's, you know, it's just,
it's just like a three hour flight.
- It's nice and close.
- Right, right.
- So just, it takes all day.
- Yeah.
- So you say three hour flight
but going to the airport alone
is like a two three hour process right?
- Going to the airport.
Then you get to the airport
go through all that at the airport.
Then the flight then get off the plane
or the stuff at the airport,
then get to wherever you're going.
It's like a 12 hour or whole day right?
- Yeah, yeah. For sure.
- And so I just spent so
much time on the planes.
I've watched through all
the movies of interest
and you know they only refresh them
once every two months or something.
- How many times you watched
a Jason Statham film?
- I watched plenty of those.
Love Statham, he's a great man.
He's fast and furious.
I watched through all of those.
And so as I switched
to podcasts for a while
so I've downloaded
podcasts and I've just, hey
the Trash Taste podcast.
Next time you catch a plane
don't forget to download
Trash Taste first.
So I went through that
and podcasts are kind of good
cause you kind of fall asleep with them
and then wake up and you kind
of still know what's going on.
Sort of.
But I got to a point
when my ears were sore
from things in them too
much, and I'm just like.
- Right, right.
Yeah.
- So I discovered the magic of books.
- Did you know before podcasts existed
people read these things called books.
- So there's these things right
it's called audio books
but just written down, it's crazy.
- It's incredible.
If you miss something or
if you don't understand
you can go back and read it again.
- Just read it again.
- It's amazing.
It's so efficient.
- So what kind of books are you reading?
- What am I reading at the moment?
- Like fiction nonfiction?
- Nonfiction, generally speaking.
- Nonfiction. Like autobiographies
and stuff like that or?
- Yeah. Nothing that
people want to hear about.
- Just nothing interesting.
- I have a boring hobby.
And I read books related
to that boring hobby.
- I mean, you have such
an intense job like,
I never really put a pass on you
to have a somewhat quote
unquote boring hobby.
- I mean most people who are like
I feel like half like intense showmanship
normally have like something
that kind of relaxes them.
- Brings them back down to the Earth.
- Well it's like people, you know,
who like spend all day everyday
going to like metal concerts, right?
It's like, you can't
listen to metal at home.
You gotta like relax with
some Enya or something right?
- There was a very successful, he was like
he was a quarterback in the NFL
and he was like one of the
most feared quarterbacks
in the league when he was playing.
And his hobby was to knit.
So there's this gigantic
like 200 kilo man.
Knitting scarves for grandma and whatnot.
- It sounds like a very therapeutic.
- Yeah. That's what he said.
He said it calmed him down.
What are your boring hobbies?
Or interesting hobbies?
- Funnily enough like,
because our job is our
hobby or as a hobby right
we've had to like, I guess
try to find hobbies outside
of our hobby.
- Try new hobbies.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Because every hobby that
like, at least I've pursued
I've somehow monetized it.
And it's kind of like turned into a job.
- Well I'm kind of the same thing.
Everything that once was a
passion for me is now the job.
So I know exactly what you're saying.
- Exactly, exactly.
- So what do you do? What do you do?
- I mean, definitely exercises for me.
- Connor McGregor, Ohh Connor McGregor
we're not here to take part
we're here to take over.
Ohh look at the Irish. The fighting Irish.
- Connor's not Irish, he's not an Irish.
- I was just gonna say,
I guess in some aspects
you know, exercise for you
probably is part of the job.
I feel like for me,
cause I don't, you know
I don't really need to fucking do it.
I just do it cause for me.
- That's great. What do you do?
- Cardio and lifting stuff.
- Good, good.
- Lifting weights like a
monkey, I guess feels like.
- Like a monkey.
- That's what it feels like.
You don't you ever just feel
like I'm just literally
just lifting things.
And I come back the next day
and I come back and lift things again.
And sometimes I sit there
and I'm thinking like, this is so bizarre.
- Why do we do this?
- I literally just come
back and I just lift things.
Like for an hour. Isn't strange?
- I feel that way on the treadmill
where you just feel
like a fucking hamster.
Like going around the wheel.
- But it makes you feel
great. So it's like,
I need to do this.
But sometimes like you have
this existential crisis of like,
what am I doing?
- I just imagined like
aliens coming down to earth
being like, what do you
humans do for a hobby?
We lift heavy objects
and feel great about it.
They're like, okay.
- They're looking at the
treadmill thinking that
it's to generate electricity.
(everyone laughing)
We spend electricity and make it work.
- It's like you do this for fun?
- Personally. I just find that, you know,
I'm not really trying
to get like, you know
in any particular shape.
I just find that I sleep better.
I feel better when I do it, occasionally.
- It's very good for you.
Let's do some promotion of exercise.
Trash Taste listeners,
you should try exercising.
- I feel like, you know
when I mentioned, everyone was like,
Oh, he's trying to be like a
Chad or some kind of meathead.
It's like, no, it's just.
- What's a chad?
- Oh my.
You are a literally a Chad.
- You are a Chad.
- Hang on just a second.
I feel like I'm supposed to be insulted.
What the hell is a chad?
- Okay, okay.
- No, no, no.
- Because I know that you
people in the United Kingdom
refer to a bogan as a chav.
Is that a different word?
- No, no, no.
- It's completely different.
- So, so, wait wait.
Okay don't say anything.
When you hear the word
Chad, what comes to mind?
What image springs to mind?
- The kid who lived next
door when I was growing up.
- You don't think of that
American guy in the film,
who's like the kind of
bully kind of, you know.
- Like a jock?
- That's where the meme came from.
- Oh really. He's name is Chad.
- Like really a lot of
like American films.
- Like the bully is always
a Chad or something.
- Yeah. The jock in the
high school was always Chad.
- Or like buddy, or something like that.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- So that's where the meme came from.
And that means like now it's
kind of adopted into someone
who's just like, now it just means
like someone who I guess.
- Who exercises.
- No, no, no.
- Not even that,
it's just kind of like a
strong-willed man I'd say.
- Like very high
self-esteem like, you know
like hell yeah, I'm the shit kind of.
- Someone who exudes confidence.
- Is Joe Rogan a Chad?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I would say he's a Chad.
- I feel like it used to just mean
guy who's ripped and massive
and it kind of looked
like blurred along the way
to be just like, yeah.
- Like guy who exudes
self-confident energy.
- But yeah.
You know, a lot of,
sometimes people try and like
mock the-
- Why are you so confuse?
- You young people are
appropriating names.
Karen, that name has
been ruined. Now Chad.
We have already destroyed Susan.
Sorry South African Susan
for listening, I'm sorry.
- Yeah, then it started what was the,
was the Chad versus the virgin as well.
- Yeah. Chad versus the virgin.
- Like the virgin was
the opposite of the Chad.
- Someone who just was like-
- Self deprecating perhaps.
- Low self esteem.
Couldn't get girls.
- That's a virgin?
A virgin is typically pure
and innocent and delightful.
- That's the Japanese
way of thinking about it.
I would say. That's the
Japanese definition of virgin.
- Hang on. What pure and delightful?
- Pure in like, you know, untainted.
- That's everyone's idea of a virgin.
- Not on the internet.
- The internet doesn't know
what it's talking about.
- Those group of hive mind
of every beautiful country.
They don't know what
they are talking about.
- No, I was not talking
about who's in the internet.
- What are their hobbies?
We didn't get to their hobbies then.
- Yeah, right.
- Anyway, your hobbies,
tell me about your hobbies.
- So you are a Chad.
- You are officially certified Chad.
- Maybe I should change
my name to Lady Chad.
- Honestly.
If you are internet
rebranding, it might work.
- Could work, could work.
Like I didn't know I was Chad.
- You know what that would be perfect for?
That would be like a second channel name
for a YouTube channel, right?
- You're main channel is Ladybeard.
- My workout channel is Lady Chad?
- Lady Chad.
- Dude, this is like
wasted marketing potential.
- What's up you fucking
pussies, it's Lady Chad.
Today, Top 10 ways to lift.
- One of the joyous things
about being a cross-dresser
and a martial artist is.
Probably Chad's actually
when I was younger,
jocks the kind of dudes
who wanted to fight,
they would come and
they would want to fight
the cross-dresser straight away.
- Right.
Since I'm a martial artist.
It's a beautiful thing.
When a man in a skirt knocks out a Chad.
With a jumping spin kick.
That's a thing of beauty.
- You just get Chun Li on your ass, right?
- Yeah it is.
- Exactly.
- It was good. It was good.
- Okay. So like that's the other thing
I wanted to ask as well
is about like the martial artist.
Cause I don't think we
got like fully into how
you developed or you
decided to kind of do that
as like a thing that you do, right?
- I still want to find
out your hobbies later.
- There's so many things
I want to ask actually.
- So how did you grew,
so obviously, you know,
you grew appreciation
towards wrestling through watching WWE,
stuff like that right?
So is that kind of the same
thing with martial arts as well?
- Oh, with martial arts.
I, you know I was, took an
interest in it from a young age
I think like probably like potentially you
and yourself as well
bullied a lot as a
child, youngest sibling.
- I'm the oldest sibling.
- I'm the middle sibling.
- I am an only child.
- Well, you're spoiled aren't you.
Everybody hail the elephant God.
No siblings. Two parents
bless you with attention.
- I love how the one
person you didn't point at
is the youngest sibling.
- The other middle child.
- I'm a middle, yeah.
- High five middle child.
- Are you middle?
- I'm three in a lineup of four.
- Oh, yeah. So I'm same.
- We both got red beards.
Me and Connor, hey,
Connorbeard new collaboration.
- You're basically the same person.
- Yeah, you're welsh me. Not in a skirt.
- Not quite it is.
Physique, bit quite
lacking in that department.
- It's like the Pokemon evolution.
(everyone laughing)
I can see the meme on Reddit already.
You take one of your cosplay videos.
- It's evolving.
Somebody make that in
the subreddit please.
- Anyway, martial arts.
- This is awesome. How it began
and how's it going, right?
- You versus the guy they
told you not to worry about.
- Anyways, martial arts.
- Yes, I got bullied a lot.
I liked the karate kid movies.
- You got bullied?
- Yeah, man.
That was a, I was a fat kid.
- Oh okay.
- No one's ripped in school.
Except that one kid who's
really thin and has abs.
Fuck that kid by the way.
That kid sucks.
- Eats pizza, drinks beer all
day. Still got a six pack.
- Somehow still has abs.
- It ain't right.
They say God ain't got no
favorites. Bullshit man.
- So what like martial arts did you take?
- I started in TaeKwonDo and
then I went into Capoeira.
- Oh wow.
Then I went into Muay Thai
and then from there the flood Gates open.
I went to Jeet Kune Do,
Kali, Freestyle grappling,
Hapkido, Wushu.
- Where'd you find the time to do that?
How long does it take
to learn a martial arts
or did you just like
dabble in it and learn?
- No no no. I mean it's-
You hear that? That's not good. Sorry.
That was bad broadcasting.
- No it's okay.
- It's all good.
- No, you just start training.
The thing about training
is it's just the thing
that you do isn't it.
It's like, I started training TaeKwonDo.
They had TaeKwonDo at school.
And so then on Friday after school
it was the thing that I
did just went to TaeKwonDo.
- Yeah but you also listed off about like
nine different types of martial arts.
- You start training and you know,
develop your skills and
you develop an interest.
And so then you get exposed
to other martial arts
and you say that looks interesting.
Looks interesting cause you
have a space of comparison now
on what you're learning and
what they seem to be learning.
So now you can say, all right,
well that looks interesting.
It looks like something that could help
with what I'm trying to achieve.
- Right, right.
- So then you kind of
end up expanding right.
- So what would you say
is like your favorite type
I guess, or like one thing
you learned from the most.
- TaeKwonDo is my first love, you know?
So that's kind of the one.
And also because I did it
when I was the youngest
it's the one that stuck in
my body the most easily.
- How young were you
when you did TaeKwonDo?
- Started at 13.
- 13. Wow.
- Yeah. And this is the thing
like I got flexible
before I became a teenager
and my flexibility was
naturally taken away.
- Right.
- That's allowed me to stay flexible.
I can still do the high
kicks and the splits.
- You can do splits?
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- I'll do them on this
table if you want to.
- No, no, no.
- That's why I added, if you want.
So yeah, it started TaeKwonDo.
Can't remember the rest of the question.
- Just wondering how it started.
- Martial arts, I mean, is,
is I wonder what is there
like a scale of like this
martial arts is more useful
than this one, cause I've seen
in like a bunch of other
stuff that there's just
so many martial arts that seem
like they're like almost I
actually are fake or like
but they're not, you know,
is that controversial
to say, I don't know.
- Well look this debate has raged
in the martial arts community
since the dawn of time.
So this is, everyone
has an opinion on this.
And now that we've got, you know,
competitive mixed martial arts everyone,
the consensus seems to be
Muay Thai for your striking
Brazilian jujitsu for your grappling.
But then you've got to understand as well
that's sport in a cage
when there are rules.
So then if there's no
rules if you're in war
or self-defense in the street or something
then you have systems like Krav Maga
which is all based
around murder basically.
- Right, right, right.
- So like there are other styles,
like a particular Kung Fu styles
where you never do anything
except strike the eyes and
the throat and the groin.
That's literally all
you do in the whole art.
So there's no, in my opinion
there's no best system or anything.
It's just depends on what
you're doing with it.
- Right.
- And there are different, you know
different round pegs to
fit it to round holes
and square pegs for square holes.
- Have you ever done MMA?
- I've trained MMA.
I haven't fought.
I was actually interested in fighting.
We were going to do it
a couple of years ago.
I actually started training for it.
- Finally found a thing
this man hasn't done yet.
- I started training for it
but it just became apparent
that it was like on a cost benefit ratio.
It wasn't really, wasn't really good.
Well there's a lot that
goes into it right.
I was gonna need a good two
years of consistent trainings.
Probably get my skills back, right.
To where they need to be for fighting.
But then also you've got to consider,
okay, so what weight am I gonna fight at?
Am I going to do a big weight cut?
Let's say I do that, then afterwards
okay, well now that's going
to affect my wrestling
cause now I'm skinny.
- Right, right.
- But then also let's say I
do the fight and it goes well
what does that really lead to
more opportunities to fight.
I don't really want to be a
professional fighter, you know
but now I've organized my
whole life for that sake.
- Right.
- So you know. And like.
And that's if the fight goes, well
if the fight goes badly,
I just look like a frickin' moron don't I.
I need plastic surgery, you know.
I'd probably you know, need
to go back home, you know? So.
- You trained for two years
to get publicly get beaten up.
- Right, right, right, right.
- Gods that's tough.
- Yeah. So when I
thought about it actually
I've trained MMA and I
really liked the training.
I was, I was interested in fighting.
- What's like the difference
between training MMA
and training just a normal martial arts?
- MMA it's everything mixed together.
- Right.
- But you've done so
many already. Right? So.
- Yeah, but you got quite a specific like
rule set in MMA that must
be followed, you know,
you're fighting in
either a cage or a ring.
- Right.
- So it's built for that environment.
So in MMA you do a lot
of work against walls
so there's a lot of
grappling against walls
because you naturally have
a wall that you get to meet
at some point.
And you can't go further than that.
- Right.
- But then, you know, if you
were fighting in the desert,
that would not be the case.
So there's a specific rule set,
so you train for that rule set
for the skill set required
for that environment.
Where else like if you're going to do like
straight self-defense or something,
it depends on what
attitude you wanna take.
- That's interesting.
Cause I've always wanted
to get into martial arts,
but I didn't know
which martial arts to
start with basically.
Cause there's so many.
- Is there, I guess like
a kind of a difficulty
or is it like, I assume.
It's more like, you know.
What is like the easiest type
of martial arts to get into
if you have like no prior knowledge in it.
Cause I assume there are some
martial arts where it's like
you need to have some base
level of martial arts.
- Cause they're all systems.
So when you start training the system
you start at the beginning.
- Right, right.
So no one's going to put you in.
- So there's no like type of
martial art where it's like
you need to have like prior
knowledge of basic Kung Fu?
- There's no 10 hit combo
that you need to memorize.
- There would be for particular
like particular forms
not the art itself, particular
training environments.
Like if you want to go
to this guy's school
you need to have 10 years
experience or whatever.
But not for the art itself. No.
- Right.
- Straight up, if you're
jumping into, you know,
expert level when you're a beginner
then you're just making a silly decision.
- Yeah, honestly.
- Moving on from martial arts.
Stunt man. What does that involve?
How did you train for that?
What'd you do on the job?
- Freaking stunts is bonkers man.
Being a stunt man is a tough gig.
- I bet.
- All right. So for me it was like,
actor so performer and martial artists,
so those two things just
naturally evolve into pro
wrestling eventually right.
But dude stunts is hard.
Firstly, you got to decide, you know,
are you just going to do stunt?
Like what I did was, you
know, punching and kicking
and falling down basically.
It was fight scenes.
But then stunts also includes cars
you know, boats getting set on fire.
- Yeah.
- People, some stunt man have to like
flip the cars over while they're innit.
Which is just like.
- That's a whole new skill set right.
So It really like, you know,
it's saying, what about stunts?
It's kinda like saying how
long is a piece of string?
There's so many different
things you can do.
You can be like falling
off buildings and things.
- So what was like some
of the stuff that you did?
- So for me, I was doing
fight scenes, right?
So like I trained in the
Hong Kong style of action
and my master, I shouldn't call my master,
the guy who was training me.
He was on Jackie Chan's stunt team
throughout the nineties and naughties.
So he did movies like
he did a couple of the Rush Hours.
He did Shanghai Noon.
- Oh wow.
- He did some of the
smaller Hong Kong ones.
Like the Twins Effect,
these kind of movies, right?
But like the way they
work in Hong Kong is like
I should stop saying like so
much, that's not good is it?
- You say it less than us.
- The way they like, oh
my God I did it again.
The attitude, okay.
The slogan of the Hong
Kong stuntman association
he told me when he was in
it, risk life save money.
So that's the kind of
attitude you're dealing with.
- Wow.
- No bullshit.
- If you, Dude I have never had
a harder teacher in my life.
This dude was so tough.
It's like, you're expected
to back flip off a balcony
whilst on fire into a
pool of broken glass.
And if you're like a little bit hesitant
he's like, No, No. You're so weak.
What's wrong with you?
Harden up. Harden up.
- That is the ultimate Chad.
- It's just like a psychopath.
- But the stunts attracts
kind of type A personality.
- Yeah.
- He was like, he was
telling me stories about when
he was back in Australia
he was from Melbourne.
In Australia before he went
to Hong Kong was with Jackie.
Just the stuff he did just as
a thing to do, was bonkers.
- What, like as a hobby?
- No, it's a hobby but like,
you kind of do it towards stunts sort of,
but he was like one day
we were driving past a
train station in Melbourne.
And you know, there's like the bridge
that goes over the train tracks.
And then there's like a pole sticking up
like 10 meters away from it or something.
A pole with the dingy dongy
lights on it or something.
And he was like,
yeah so when I was younger,
before I went to Hong Kong
I was gonna jump off the
bridge onto the pole.
Yeah. I was gonna do that.
Yeah. We didn't have a camera at the time.
I'm like, what?
You know, jump off. What?
- Just for fun?
- Just telling me to jump from this bridge
onto catch a pole, just yeah.
- To be like, I did it.
- Here's a thing to do.
I think his attitude was he would film it
and it will become part
of his stunt show reel.
I think that was his attitude.
But that's the kind of people like,
just fearless men.
- So you're doing stupid shit,
like jumping off
buildings into like glass?
Where do you draw the line?
- I didn't. Cause I'm not that talented.
Other people-
- Talented?
- What talents you need?
I mean, like, how do you train for them?
That's what I wanna know.
- There's a natural level
of talent that's required.
So the guys who become a career stuntmen
generally speaking, the
kids who were, you know
the fastest runners in school.
The kids who had naturally
very physically active.
I'm not I was a fat kid at school.
So I've got a level of
skill just cause I trained
but I don't have the
natural talent for it.
- Right.
- These guys, man, like
I've got friends who now
are doing the stunts in all the,
like the Marvel films or so forth.
And they're just,
the moment they were born,
they were better than me
after a hundred years of training,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like my Capoeira teacher.
- That guy throw himself off buildings
so goddamn good. I wish that were me.
- It's like they back
flipped out of the womb
with a six pack.
And a charming smile, you know.
It's just ridiculous.
Like, goodness.
Yeah so it's like,
that's the level of natural
talent that's required.
But also when you get to that,
a lot of them just type-A personality.
- I mean you have to be,
you can't, you can't like.
- If you're willing to
be hit by a car, you know
like just stand there, we're
going to drive a car into you.
Okay.
You know, it's so frickin' crazy.
- Good take, good take.
- Was it good? Was it good?
All right let's do it again.
- Just on the ground legs
broken, is that good?
- A lot of wrestlers as well.
It's like, you know, okay.
It's funny. When you're pro wrestlers,
you're backstage in the locker room.
Everyone's normally so mellow.
It was just like, Oh.
So chilled out.
And then, okay, so we'll go onto the ring
and three minutes in or so
you can hit me with the baseball bat.
Wrap up a barbed wire.
He's like, hmm.
They hit me with it here last week
it's still healing.
So you better hit me with it here.
Really? Are you sure?
That's what you want me to do?
Let's take a quick break
for this one minute break.
And we'll be right back
on the voice of Africa radio network.
- It's funny because wrestlers will be
in the locker room and they all Oh, Oh,
they're taping up knees and things.
They go out to the ring and it's.
And they're superheroes, right?
They go back, they're all
bleeding and everything.
Blood everywhere.
Stunt people and pro wrestlers,
it's what a life.
- What a life.
- What a life eh?
- Credits roll.
- What a gimmick.
- I mean, I suppose like
pro wrestlers is just a natural
evolution of stuntmen right?
Because it's just like,
it's more controlled stunts
and you add a narrative to it.
- I felt that way.
And also the guys who tend go into stunts
tend to be much more like
talented with the physical stuff.
And I was better at the
character performance type stuff.
So for me it seemed like a
much more natural evolution.
- What are some of the craziest
stunts you've had to do?
- Well, I wasn't that good.
So I didn't get to do
that much amazing stuff.
Jumping off balconies done some of that.
It's not that hard.
- I mean, I, I dunno.
I wouldn't want to jump
off a balcony personally.
- How tall are we talking here?
- Not that tall.
Second story.
- What the fuck.
- It's still pretty
tall. I wouldn't do it.
- My trainer was like, you're
weak, you're such a sissy.
He's doing like 20 stories
and things, you know.
Just insane.
- This is how real Chad does it.
- Oh my God, man.
It was never good enough.
- Some people are just
like cockroaches right?
They just can't die.
- Honestly, honestly.
- Like honestly.
- In pro wrestling a hit over the head
with one of those fluorescent light tubes.
That was good. That actually doesn't hurt,
but it does cut you.
So we end up bleeding.
- Have you ever gotten
injured or anything like that?
- Like properly injured.
- Well I probably been
concussed, but didn't realize.
You know what I'm saying?
- How do you not realize.
- I don't know what you're
saying, unfortunately.
- If I get concussed, I
immediately realize it.
- Do you really though?
That's the thing about concussion.
You don't know what's going on.
That's a whole thing about concussion,
you don't know what's going on.
So you need someone to stop you
and be like, you're concussed.
We need to do the whatever
happens after concussions.
We do what people who've
done a first aid course.
- It's like people who
play American football
like never know that they're concussed.
- Yeah, exactly. They go
back straight to the field.
- Oh geez.
- I think it's like
they have like the most,
I think they die early
cause they have so much brain damage.
They're just hitting
their head constantly.
But they don't know.
- So it's the same with MMA fighters
in training just getting jabbed,
just getting little punches.
They get like compounded
brain damage from that.
It's not from getting knocked out.
It's just from little shots over.
Anyway, so light over the head,
broken glass.
Sorry, not broken glass.
Barbed wire did some of that.
- You look like Jesus?
- Hit with a shovel.
I got hit in the head with a shovel.
- You got hit in the head with a shovel?
- It was a great weapon.
- Like how hard are we talking?
Like just like a little like boop or?
- Bonked!
- Oh fuck.
- It was a great weapon.
But if you hit it with the concave side,
it's not that bad on your skull.
The convex side would really mess you up.
The concave side, you know,
folds onto your skull.
- Right, right.
But like to control that right,
in the swing, would it be
I feel it's a lot harder than it looks.
- Because like there's
a image in pro wrestling
that you know, pro wrestling is fake
and everything like that.
But obviously the stunts are real.
Like how hard you have
to go for the stunts
that you do in pro wrestling?
- Well, it depends.
It depends on you, I
mean give it hell really.
- So when you're saying the shovel right?
In my mind my immediate thought is,
guy swing shovel
tries his best to stop
it, but it still hits you.
Is that what's happening?
Or is he literally going, like,
I'm gonna hit you with the shovel.
- No. Hit me as hard as you can.
- Why?
- What?
- Cause I guess like,
the audience needs to
hear the sound, right?
- To hear the sound.
And also it's you know, like just-
- Get one of those soundboard in the back.
- When you're wrestling,
you want to do it, you know
there's an element of, come on, you know?
- No I don't.
That's why, that's why
I'm not a pro wrestler.
I'm a virgin.
This Chad versus the virgin.
- I think you're making
anyone listening to this
sound like virgin.
Frankly, frankly I don't
want to be hit in the head
with a shovel.
- I used to love it.
It's a young man's game,
it's a young man's game.
- You're talking about this
like it's a past time, you know.
- I feel like, why is it, you know,
when a kid says that, it's like
oh God, this kid is going nowhere.
When an adult says it,
wow, he's such a manly adult.
I feel if my son comes up to me, age five,
daddy, I love being hit
in the head by a shovel.
I'll be like.
- I dropped you one too
many times looks like.
- It's you know, oy Chad's dig it.
- Is it just the sheer manly energy
and the testosterone going around.
Is it just like, just hit, fucking hit me.
- I mean, I guess once
you're on the stage.
- It's adrenaline going on.
- It's the adrenaline
and there's something,
somehow emotionally
satisfying with it as well.
So from an acting standpoint,
acting is all emotion and so forth.
Wrestling is the most
emotional work I've ever done
because there's so much
emotion involved in,
being hit.
- It's real.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So, it's highly emotional
and there's something satisfying about it.
It's you know, like I say,
it's a young man's game.
You want to be doing
that in your twenties.
- Well yeah, I think I saw it,
what was it like the general
of the thing on the WWE.
I think I watched that
and they were saying
that they like they're
all contractors in WWE.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, yeah.
So they're all contractors that
can't work for anyone else.
- Okay.
- Oh, wow.
- And then, you know, once they're done
they don't really get much
health benefits or anything.
So a lot of them ended up you know,
being really injured later on.
And they're just like, see ya.
- That's getting fixed nowadays.
- I hope so.
- Back in the day lots of that.
But you know, there's
something satisfying about it.
I had, this was not really dangerous,
but we found, you know those
plastic wet floor signs
that go into triangle?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was a fantastic weapon.
Because when you hit someone with them,
the two piece of plastic clap together.
So it makes a really loud noise.
- Doesn't hurt.
- It doesn't hurt.
So you go crack, crack, crack
hit someone on the head
with over and over again.
So I did that in a
match once it was great.
I got hit in the head a bunch of times.
We did this, this spot then later on,
I'm going home, I'm on the train.
And it's some like,
young girl next to me.
She sits down next to me.
She's like.
I'm like.
How are you?
And she was like.
She got up and like
changed seats or something.
And I was like, that was odd.
And then like we got off at the station
and I walked past some reflective surface.
We walked past some reflective surface
my whole like face had turned purple.
The whole thing was purple.
- Just like Megamind.
(everyone laughing)
- I'm having a casual chat,
it's a nice evening, isn't it?
Purple face.
- You're just scaring
all the Japanese people
from foreigners.
They're like, fucking hell this foreigners
are fucking weird.
- Jesus Christ.
- I did a gimmick with fire once,
but that wasn't, that wasn't
bad from a pain perspective.
- Wait, wait, wait.
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
- You said it wasn't bad
from a pain perspective.
What was it bad, what
perspective was it bad in?
- An insurance perspective.
That's the perspective for which was bad.
From the, you'll never wrestle
in this building again,
perspective.
- Oh, right, right.
- I mean doing anything with fire
most 90% of the time
requires some kind of safety.
- We started dueling, we just thought
the swords would be fantastic.
- We had a stick with a
cloth wrapped around it.
It'll be drenched in
gasoline or something.
(everyone laughing)
And then, we were safe,
we had a bucket of water next to the ring.
- A single bucket?
- That's not how fire works.
- There's a fire truck right there,
the bucket of water, the
piss bucket on the side.
- We'll just go on stage and
taking your like insurance.
- Just set that on fire.
- We had a thing one time with
just needles, reused needles.
We though that it was just
be a great bit, you know.
- There's a shower at the
facility. I just wash it off.
- In Japan That's what
most of them are like.
The death match workers in Japan
That's what they're like.
They'll go into the ring
and be bleeding everywhere
then afterwards (speaking
foreign language)
Then just go have a
shower and wash it off.
Yeah. So you go to the shower afterwards,
There's blood everywhere,
all over the shower floor.
- Oh my god.
- Goddamn, goddamn.
- There's only two times when there's like
a shit ton of blood in the shower,
that's at a wrestling match and prison.
- My God, Joey.
- Oh my God.
- I'll leave that up to your imagination.
- Anyway.
- I was not thinking that.
- I did not expect that joke from Joey.
I didn't see that coming.
- I did not as well.
- How long have you been
holding that joke in?
- It's like, finally I get to say it.
The perfect setup.
- He's been holding onto
that joke for years.
- Like I've never found a place to say it.
Today's the day.
- That's just The Shawshank
Redemption right there.
- I've Hung out with you so many times
just on a personal level.
But like, I guess like
we never really go into like
as deeply as what we, what you do right?
So it was like, I don't know.
I mean, I, for one have
never met a pro wrestler
who was also a metal singer
who is also a cross dresser
who also was a stuntman.
- A martial artist.
- A martial artist as well.
- Voice actor.
- Messiah as well.
- Savior of mankind.
- Let me tell you about the
time I split the red sea.
- Let me ask you some questions.
- Okay.
- At what age did you
begin anime person titties.
- You mean my YouTube channel?
- Yeah.
- I was, oh God. It's 2013, so I was 19.
- You were 19?
- Yeah.
- And how old are you now?
- 26.
- Are you?
- Yeah.
- I thought you were, okay.
- What did you think I was?
- Well, younger than that,
but thinking about it,
I met you 2016 when you
were like 21 or something.
- Yeah, yeah. I was like 22, 23.
- To me you're eternally 21, forever 21.
- Forever 21. Is not quite forever, is it?
Yeah. I dunno.
Yeah. So it was my first
year of university.
So that was like a hobby.
And then by the time I
graduated university,
I was like, Oh I can make this living.
- Ass kickin'.
- Cool.
- What'd you study at uni?
- I did, it was this degree
called design computing
which is basically like,
think of a bachelor of arts
but more technology-based.
So I learnt like music production,
I learnt like 3D modeling,
graphic design, website design
all that kind of stuff.
- Surely that's come
in useful in this life.
- Well yeah, cause I learned video editing
from one of the courses as well.
So I was like, Oh, I like video editing.
- That's bangin'.
- Yeah. I'm no longer
the host of the show now.
This is Ladybeard featuring Trash Taste.
- On the voice of Africa radio network.
- Let's be honest it was Ladybeard
featuring Trash Tastes from the beginning.
- Let me ask another question actually.
Aussie, Brit, Brit.
- Yeah, got the fucking
ashes right here man.
- Explain the choice
of this American word,
trash in your name.
Why is we're not the podcast
called the rubbish rebel?
- Unfortunately we have
to cater to Americans
with almost everything in our life really.
- Well also because Trash
Taste is kind of a term
that we use in like the anime community.
- Oh really?
- Yeah. So like if
somebody has trash taste
it means like, Oh, you know,
you're you're into like the
the crappier shows and like
the more guilty pleasure type
of show shows, ah you have
trash tastes in anime.
- We haven't spoken about anime at all.
- We haven't.
- Have you watched anime?
Do you watch anime?
- Yeah, let me explain my anime bit.
- Go for it.
- So I used to be quite an anime fan,
but I had to switch all my content over
to things that would help
with my language learning
as opposed to watching
for the sake of leisure.
- Right.
- So for the past three years,
my prime watching of anime
has consisted of Peppa
Pig dubbed into Mandarin.
I've watched Mandarin Peppa Pig.
I used to watch it every morning.
- I didn't even know there
was a Mandarin Peppa Pig.
- I wake up and I'll put
on Peppa Pig in Mandarin.
- And that's how you learned Mandarin.
- The idea was when my
brainwaves were still
whatever they are when you're
sleeping, like whatever.
I absorb the language at that point.
So I listen to it going to
sleep and then also waking up.
That was my strategy.
- Wow.
- And also Peppa Pig,
cause it's a children's show
means the language is nice
and you know, basic.
- Easy to understand yeah.
- Normal life language, as
opposed to slaying dragons
and stuff that happens in
more interesting anime.
And also the voices are
recorded in the studio.
So they're crisp and easy to hear. So.
- Yeah. Actually that's one
question I wanted to ask.
How did you learn Japanese?
- Japanese? Well, I.
- Because I'm sure many
people watching this podcast
would like to know that.
- I don't recommend you
learn Japanese the way I did.
What I recommend you do
is you go get the school
get the teachers, get the books,
just do it the traditional way.
There's a big push in the
language learning community
to not do that anymore.
That's what has worked
for thousands of years.
That's why it is the system.
- Why is there a push to not do that?
- Cause everyone's like, no,
you should make learning fun.
No you shouldn't.
Learning should be boring and tedious
and you should bash your way through it
with your teacher and your exercise.
Cause that's how you actually
build the language properly
from the ground up.
What I did was I got Pimsleur's Japanese
and I would you know, went
through those programs and stuff.
And then I did some lessons with a tutor,
but it was pretty haphazard.
I'm gonna turn up in Japan
and just try to figure it out.
Just no one around me spoke
English to figure it out.
But now, now seven
years into that journey.
Now my Japanese is full of
holes and grammatical problems
and things that Shiori's
now trying to fix.
So it's now much harder to
go back and fix bad habits.
And this just start out problems.
That's why we do that.
You grew up speaking it.
- Yes. It's my first language.
- Is it really?
- Yeah.
- Damn.
- So you can't really participate
in the learning conversation.
How'd you folks learn it?
- I mean, we're still learning.
- Are you really?
- Yeah, because I mean-
- (speaking Japanese)
- Oh, it won't be
Daijoubu for the audience.
- That's okay.
- Sorry audience.
Good point, you pulled that
back quickly that was good.
- I mean, Connor goes to classes,
Garnt you don't go to classes, right?
- No.
I mean, it's been hard because
there's no way to get around
it without putting time
into it.
And time is, I feel like the hardest find
the hardest thing to find as an adult,
because everyone I've talked
whose learned Japanese
no matter what way they went through,
what path they went through
there's no getting around,
just putting the hours into it.
And it's like difficult
in our situation because
with our situation, you know,
it's different from your situation.
Cause we can, we can go about our day
and just not speak any Japanese at all
and be completely fine with it
cause we work from home.
So it goes down to having
to find time outside of your schedule
to like learn Japanese.
- Cause I'm sure if Garnt and Connor
were thrown into a situation where like,
you're stuck in this village in Japan,
when not a single person
can speak English.
So you just have to get, you
know, make your way through it
by trying to speak as
much Japanese as possible.
I'm sure anybody in that
situation will be like,
all right,
I guess I've got to start
speaking Japanese, right?
- That's one option.
- It's unfortunate cause I mean,
it's obviously great that
we have so much work to do
and that, you know, it is
so successful cause you know
I would love to take a year off
and just do nothing and learn it.
- I'd love to do that as well.
- Unfortunately it makes
literally no sense right now
to do that because you know,
everything's going so well.
- I reckon if I had control your schedule
I could get your Japanese
learning stuck in there.
You've gotta be ruthless about it.
You've gotta find little windows,
little windows of time
where you can slip it in.
And the things like first
thing in the morning.
Yo get Peppa Pig dubbed into Japanese.
I'm not joking. I'm not joking.
That's great because you can see,
the situations they're
going through are so basic.
And every day, this is my mom.
This is my dad.
We're kicking a ball. You know.
Go through that, that's
gonna teach you properly.
Then also get your damn books
and your teachers, and your class.
- How many seasons were Peppa Pig?
- It's not that many.
- How long before you
started learning Japanese
to the point where you
were like, all right,
I'm pretty pretty fluent now.
- Being in Japan,
it was one year before I was
not a total moron anymore.
Two years before I felt somewhat competent
but I'd say five years before
I really feel like I can.
- Talk to anyone, talk about anything.
- I don't even really still
feel I can do that, you know.
If I don't know someone,
if they start doing something like weird
like talking keigo, see
you later. I can't do that.
See you later man.
That's like a different language.
Next stop they're pulling out Kansai-ben.
I'm like, who's this jackass?
What'd you do talking to
me like some Kansai person.
- Oh yeah, I mean like you
know, keigo I guess is like,
you know, everybody, everywhere in Japan
you know, usually, you know, uses it.
But when it comes to different dialects,
like even I'm sometimes completely lost.
- It's not very confidence inspiring
when you talk to natives and they're like
I don't know what they're saying.
And I'm like, what the
fuck am I suppose say?
- Like Kansai-ben right?
It's like, because you hear it so much
on TV and stuff like that.
It's like one dialect
where I'm like, okay yeah.
I can kind of figure
out what you're saying
but if I'm in like, you know,
Okinawa or like middle of
nowhere in Hokkaido all right?
Then I'll be like, I think
you're speaking Japanese
but I couldn't tell you
what the fuck you're saying.
- Did you have to, so you
grew up speaking Japanese,
but did you have, were
there parts of the language
you needed to study?
Like particles or anything like that?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So like I did the JLPT-
- Okay.
- Which is like the Japanese
language proficiency test.
And I got N1 which is the highest level
I had to study for that.
I got that when I was
like 14, I think 14, 15
but I studied like fucking crazy for that.
- Good man, see he studied.
- That's the thing,
people think that like, Oh, fluent people
well you know, people who have
it as their first language
have it easy because
you don't have to study.
No, that's complete bullshit.
You have to study just
as hard as everybody else
if you want to get good at it.
- Yeah. Cause the thing is you also,
you said, you also said you
speak five languages as well.
- Fluent in English.
Half-assed at another four.
- What other four? What
other four do you speak?
- So, Japanese Cantonese,
Mandarin, German.
- German?
- I learned German in high school.
- Oh, okay.
- And you've remember it?
- Yeah. But it's been,
but I haven't spoken it
for a long time.
I went there on exchange.
So I got that native exposure.
But now I'm just big time out of practice.
So if I start trying to talk, I would need
like if you dumped me at
a German village somewhere
I'd get it back a month or two maybe.
- Right.
- But I need to go through remembering
a lot of vocab, specific bits
of grammar, how it works.
Interestingly German grammar
is not that different
from Japanese grammar.
- Yeah. A lot of Eastern
European languages actually
are kind of similar to that you know.
- Would you say that after you
learned your first language
it was like way easier
to learn other languages?
Cause that's what I've heard.
- No.
- See because I've heard
that's the thing like,
I felt, cause my grandad
could speak seven languages.
Fluently.
- I think you just learn
what system works for you.
- Yeah. Yeah.
But like I also heard that like languages
are a lot similar to instruments
where the second one is always the hardest
and then it gets easier and easier
because you, every with
every new thing you learn,
you use your base knowledge
from the previous thing you've learned
to kind of build upon it.
So it was like, Oh, this is
a completely new language.
But I already know a language that has
kind of the same base sentence structure
or same vocabulary rules as this one.
- I have found that to mess me up.
- Oh really?
- Because now I'm just confused.
Now I'm going into, let's say
if I'm going from like
Japanese to Mandarin.
Now I'm trying to do Mandarin grammar
but I'm instinctively picking
Japanese words, right?
Nod that head Ashley, good man.
Ashley knows what's up.
I imagined Shiori's nodding the head.
I can't see her.
So, so, but hang on.
But you watch anime for
like a thousand hours a day.
Surely something comes from that.
- No, no. That's a fallacy.
- I never, ever intended
to learn Japanese.
When I was like, you know, 17, 18,
I thought it's cringe to want
to learn Japanese from anime.
- Look at this guy. HAHA.
Tell me more.
- Yeah, that's what I thought.
And then now I'm like,
fuck I'm such an idiot that
I thought it was cringe.
- It was like looked down
upon in the anime community.
Cause we had like the whole,
the whole like weeaboo movement where-
- Cause people will then start like trying
to talk Japanese to you online.
And it's like, what are
you doing? This is cringe.
You know, they're not really
trying to learn the language.
They're just trying to
learn a couple of phrases.
- They just want to be like
their favorite anime characters.
- Because let's be real like,
the Japanese you hear in anime,
like 99% of the time is not
the way Japanese people speak.
- That's why you can't learn from it.
- Right. Exactly.
I mean, I mean, I think
you can learn from it
but you shouldn't completely base
all your knowledge off of it.
- But it's a different level
it's once you've already got your base
you can talk about slaying dragons.
- I would also say that
watching anime with subtitles
is a wholly different
experience from watching anime
to learn it because I've,
I've realized this now
as I'm trying to learn Japanese,
that the subtitles are just distracting.
I think it's actually
worse to learn Japanese
with subtitles on,
because you either pay
attention to a Japanese
or you read the subtitles.
And it's really hard to
concentrate on doing both.
And your mind, your mind works differently
when it's just trying
to hear the language,
as opposed to just reading the subtitles.
- I think actually having
the Japanese subtitles helps more.
- I would say so as well.
- You see the sentence
and recognize some kanji.
- I reckon, you get a sentence,
you watch it and you listen
then you stop then you go back
and you play it again and you read.
- But the average anime
watcher is not gonna do that
because they just want
to listen to the story.
- So you got to study.
- Because the trade off you have to do
if you want to learn
Japanese by watching anime
is just to not enjoy the anime.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Which is the unfortunate part of it.
And it's what I realized as well.
- Do I want to ruin this thing?
This one of the last escapes I have.
- So I guess the only like
solace to that is just
like use an anime that you
already know inside and out
and then re-watch it again to be like,
all right, I already know the story.
I'm just gonna use it
as like study material.
- That's a good idea.
And you can take like foreign movies
that have been dubbed as well.
That's another good strategy.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah.
So what anime are you
folks watching as well?
- Well they know what we're watching.
What are you watching?
We never got to that.
- What's your favorite anime?
- Uh, uh.
Hang on.
Which one of those sentences
am I answering first?
- What's your favorite anime?
- Baccano.
- Nice.
- That's good choice.
- That's good taste.
- That's a really good taste.
Why you on a show called Trash Taste
when you got great taste.
- I dubbed Baccano.
- Did you?
Well, when I lived in Hong Kong,
one of my jobs there was I was a dubber.
So we dubbed anime.
- Wait, you're one of the
Hong Kong voices in Baccano?
- Yes. There was a main,
one of the main kids,
young handsome guy, Friel
or something was his name.
- Friel, that sounds really familiar.
- There's a scar?
- No, it wasn't scar boy.
- Jacuzzi?
- Young handsome not Jacuzzi.
It was one of the main kids.
- Firo?
- Yes!
Firo. I'm Firo.
I'm the old Russian man who was doing
all the reincarnation stuff.
- No fucking way.
- Really?
- Can I have a look at your resume.
- Is this like on IMDB somewhere?
- Ladybeard is a fucking
anime dub voice actor.
- What the hell haven't you done?
- This is so insane, that
it sounds like bullshit.
- We did the English dubs for Animax.
So like say you're in Hong
Kong or Singapore or something.
You can watch Animax in three languages,
Japanese, local language,
like Cantonese or English.
So we did the English
dubs for Asia on Animax.
- So that wouldn't be the
English dub that played-
- On the DVD in America, no.
It's amazing going to conventions
and talking to American
dubbers cause they're like,
yeah one episode we take
about five weeks to dub it.
We were like, we did six episodes a day.
Get them done. Get 'em done.
- I have seen clips from
a lot of the English dubs
for the English market.
- Animax.
- You don't have time to mess around.
But so I was, Tomozo in Chibi Maruko Chan.
I was Nezumi Otoko in Gegege no Kitaro.
- This is fucking insane.
- I was Grelle in Black Butler.
- You're Grelle in Black Butler?
- I'm Grelle, I'm bloody Grelle.
- What is going on?
- If for Chinese listeners
in Pleasant Goat and Big
Big Wolf, I was the wolf.
You know that show?
- You did it in Chinese?
- No, we dubbed into English.
But the original show is Chinese show.
Big time in China.
We did tons of it. We did Gundam Age.
I was the flirty dude in Gundam Age,
can't remember his name.
Gundam Sangoku Soketsuden.
- You must have really bashing these out.
I don't know what the fuck
I did, I just turn up.
- You do, you do. You show up,
what is it? All right. The
thing. Okay. All right.
Just knock them out.
- Jesus.
- So did you even know
who you were playing
or the character as well?
Or did you just turn up and
there was a script there
and you just had to read?
- Normally at the start of series
we'd get to do a little bit of research.
- And we get told, okay.
Here's approximately what
happens in the story.
Here's approximately
who your character is.
And then we figure out the voice.
We've said that with the director
we figured out the
voice we're going to do.
- No audition process?
- No.
Audition was to get hired by the studio.
So you'd been hired and
now you good enough to do.
But then we did like,
Inazuma Eleven, right?
Cause there's so many
characters in that show.
Everybody has like a hundred characters.
So you kind of, you run
out of voices, right?
The soccer teams, Cause
they rotate through
and you remember a few episodes.
You just, your team
from three episodes ago
starts their voices become
the new teams voices.
- Everyone's forced to
be Mel Brooks, basically.
It's just like, let's do a hundred voices.
Just pull them out.
- Big time, that was a great job.
But that was wiped out of
the financial crisis you see?
- Oh jeez.
- So I had a killer life before then.
Stuntman, voice actor, that was dope.
- I can't believe you're
an anime dub voice actor.
- They say you're the Jack of all trades
literally the embodiment.
- You know Omni Productions?
- Oh they have the funniest
transformers dub you have.
- That's what they were famous for.
- It's famous, because
this transformer dub
is fucking awful. It is so fucking awful.
- Is this the same company
that dubs Dragon Ball movies?
- I think there is, it might be, but yeah.
Omni dubs is like.
- Yeah.
That's what they were notorious for.
- There's like a Twitter account
dedicated to just posting clips from it
just out of context.
- What's happened to the headmasters.
Can't they fight without Chrome Dome?
- I just showed the boys some
of the transformers dubs.
- It's hilarious.
- That was before my time at the company.
- So did the quality
actually go up you know?
- I don't know, it
depends on what you think.
- Okay listen, when I'm
doing voice acting right,
I know when I'm in a project
that's garbage right?
- Of course. Cause you're
a voice actor too, yes.
- I know when I'm in
something and I'm like,
this is not going on the resume.
You know what I mean? You can tell.
Did you get that feeling
when you're doing any
of these dubs or you're like,
this is like, this is okay.
Or this is like, I don't
think this is good.
Or you just like this would work?
- Well, you know it's
like maybe sometimes,
you gotta do what you gotta do.
- I mean, I guess the fact
that we just found out
that you used to be an anime
dub voice actor says something.
- Yeah. But like, look there's
dubbing and there's dubbing.
There's kind of stuff
that you get sent to do
and it's some, you know, commercial thing
and you know, the script is
written in broken English
and you're just like, no, you just record.
Okay. And you just do it.
And then there's shows Black Butler,
which were actual shows.
Tell me about your voice acting life.
- Just started when I was,
Oh my God. How old was I? 15?
- Holy smokes.
- From like my room though.
Like just doing it for
fun. Cause I loved it.
- What, just doing like fan dubs?
- Yeah. Just doing like anything.
And then went to a start
doing that for awhile.
Got better equipment.
Had zero training for awhile.
And then manage to got
some roles very luckily.
Oh my God, one of the most
embarrassing ones is that
I've voiced like, I couldn't do this now
I think you know what I'm talking about?
You're gonna fucking love it.
So I voiced a Nigerian.
- Oh dear, you can't do that.
- So what happened was, is that,
again I was like, I was
like 17 when I did this.
It was like Age of Empires.
I'm sure you know that game.
They literally were doing a
competition when I was like
you can voice in the game.
And I was like, fantastic.
So they wanted Nigerian accents.
And so I quickly opened up
Google tab go to YouTube,
Nigerian accent example.
Listen to some guy who's Nigerian speaking
and I was like, I'm pretty
sure I can get close to this.
Submitted an audition.
Didn't think anything of it.
A year later at the like, yeah so,
yeah, we used your lines
in the game, and I'm like.
Can I re-record them?
No, They're in the game.
- The game came out yesterday.
- It's out now. I'm like, What?
But I didn't like sign
any contracts or anything.
So I don't know.
- Did you get paid for it or?
- They paid me like 200
bucks. I'm like, thanks.
Pat me on the back.
Like get him outta here.
- I was gonna say, that's
called getting it done for free.
- But like it was like it was
so long in between you know.
- Is that legal?
- I don't know.
- Can they just use your
voice without you signing?
- It's a competition.
- I'm -
I'm pretty sure when you
send in the competition,
they you know.
- The fine print probably
says something right? Yeah.
- That's amazing.
So you got into League
of Legends as a Nigerian.
- No, sorry. Age of Empires.
- Age of Empires.
- If Riot Games was
doing this, Jesus Christ.
- Sorry, sorry, sorry.
- I mean Riot Games did
redub one of their character.
- Oy, they both have
alliteration in title.
You can't blame me that much.
- It was weird cause like, you know.
I'm voicing some archer in some
DLC that like never appears.
And my mate is obsessed
with Age of Empires,
he just messaged me one day.
He's like, I think I found you
and he sends me an unlisted YouTube clip.
And it's like, you know
cause you know Age of Empires
when you're moving around the wall
It's like a dark circle
that comes visible.
And there's the Nigerian
archer walks in and he's like,
Hello. And welcome to the village.
It's literally like the
Ugandan Knuckles meme,
before the meme.
I've shown clips of it before.
Cause I just think it's so
fucking embarrassing and stupid.
- Well that's not PC.
- There's no way you could
get away with that today.
- As questionable as it
was, But even in like 2015,
that was, there was like
still no problem with that.
- Internet was a different time.
- There was never a source
of that being problematic.
Now I would never dream of
auditioning for a Nigerian.
- I mean, you're also
17 at that time right?
- Yeah I was like a literal fucking child,
I thought, I can be a Nigerian archer.
- When I first did my like
actor registry stuff in Australia,
you have to list accents you can do.
And I went through the
ones I thought I could do.
- You just bullshit.
- French or whatever.
But then it comes over like Korean,
yeah, I'll just do an impersonation
of my TaeKwonDo master, tick.
Japanese, just do a impersonation
of my friend Yuji, tick.
Which is I would never, ever,
ever need to fricking voice.
- Sorry I was doing that.
And then yeah, it just came into a thing
and start doing classes.
Got workshops, got more experienced
to professional work
at London for a while.
It was pretty chill.
- In London. So now,
you're voice acting here?
- I have done some things here.
The one thing we did, we
can't talk about it yet so.
- Yeah, yeah. Connor and
I did something recently
but we can't talk about it.
- I don't think it's been recently,
I remember you guys talking about it.
- It was ages ago, but it
still hasn't been released.
- Really? That happens a lot.
- Yeah.
- I shot a thing in 2016
that came out like a few weeks ago.
- What? Jesus Christ.
- I feel like what you do,
is you just record these things
and then it's a pleasant surprise like,
two, three years later.
When it comes out-
- Just forget about it.
- It's like, oh yeah, I did that.
- Oh God, I want to redo all my lines.
- Let's hope the world
hasn't changed around you
too much in the time.
- Yeah, I hope not.
- You're not breaking
any laws by accident.
- Hey guys, this is my
newest Nigerian role.
I recorded that seven years ago.
- Hope you like it.
- Today at the voice of
Africa radio network.
We would like you to meet
Nigerian voice actor, Connor.
- Did you have to do
like an Afrikaans accent?
Or did you have to like
ever put on an accent
for any of the anime voices you had to do?
- All the time.
- All the time?
- Because I can't really imagine
like an Australian accent.
- The problem with accents is that,
you always think you're
better at doing them
than you actually are.
Because you know, even
if you're very good,
a native will be able to pick it apart.
And they'll be like.
- Because when I did the,
I did a voice for Pop Team Epic
but like the character was-
- American.
- An American.
It was the mayor of New
York right? In the story.
(everyone laughing)
It was literally the mayor of New York.
And I was like,
and I said to the director
in Japanese I was like,
so do I have to like do
it in an American accent?
Like I can do an American
accent, but it's not great.
Like I'm just letting you know.
And he's like, no, just fucking say it.
And I'm like, all right.
So I was like okay,
I need to see like how
far the limit is right?
Because usually they don't
take the first take right?
So I can just kind of,
test the limits to see like
how far I can go before I have
to eventually redo it again.
So my first take was dead ass like,
I am the mayor of New York
and yeah, welcome everybody.
And they fucking took it.
- Well cause they don't know.
- They don't know.
- Yeah, because they don't know.
They were like, yeah, that
sounded really New York.
I'm like.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
- When I thought I was
better than I was you know,
you always listen to all these accents
and I very quickly started
dropping to like less and less.
Even now I could definitely
do an American speaking role
but I just don't want to
cause I'm scared of getting
rinsed by Americans.
So I'll only do it if I'm like
I'm a hundred percent
sure I can pull this off.
Even then I'm like.
- I mean, there's a
lot of actors out there
who are so good at doing
an American accent,
but for some reason
like when it's the other way around like.
- True. True. Yeah.
Americans doing British.
Yeah. But the thing is right is that
when you're in this really
contained environment
where you get the script before
you can really sit down
and nail the accent
in these words, you can go with it,
you can sit down with a native speaker.
You can be like,
walk me through exactly
how to pronounce this.
Cause and then people
on the spot are like,
do an American accent.
It's a totally different thing.
If you coach me, I can definitely
perform an American accent
or probably even like
other European accents
if you gave you time to do that one line.
And that's why like,
I think actors it comes off like that.
I mean, some of them are talented as fuck
just whip it out and start doing it.
But they have like linguist coach.
- Yeah, but that's when
you have like an accent
inside of you right?
You can just like, it's just natural.
- It's really difficult
to like actually just
on the fly switch to an accent.
Cause you're rewriting-
- and it sound convincing.
- The whole coding of the language.
- Yeah. Are you a voice actor too?
- I am not.
I'm the odd one out here.
I've not done any voice acting.
- That was how I got my start
doing everything that I do.
- You should do what he did,
then you can be a voice actor too.
- I'm not a good voice actor.
- I mean Garnt's voice
actor in his own things.
- I mean like the problem with me is that
there's no way for me not to sound like me
and also I'm shit at
doing accents as well.
- Sometimes. Good though.
Like some people do
want like very distinct.
- I want that voice.
- Very distinct voices.
- Like I hear like my voice acting,
which is like I've done like,
like bare bones voice acting
because like I did like,
do you know what an unabridged series is?
- I think so.
- Yeah. So it's like,
it's like a parody dub kind
of an anime series right?
And so I did, I did that for fun.
And I would like cast all the main roles
as like other voice actors.
And I would cast myself as
just all the filler characters
that I couldn't be bothered to look for.
And I just sound like
myself in every character.
- Listen, it's either that
or generic American accent
like one on one that like,
no one can distinguish.
- Like I can reckon anytime
I used to watch like
a Gigguk abridged, like
I could immediately tell.
- Oh yeah, you can tell when it's Garnt.
It's so obvious when it's Garnt.
- But that has a charm to it, I find.
It's like, you know, watching something.
And then all of a sudden
you hear your favorite voice actor right?
Being like oh shit, there he is.
- I am Morgan Freeman.
- Exactly.
- I actually am, pulled my skin off.
What are your favorite animes?
- Oh my God, here we
go. It's the question.
- Yeah. That is the question
we get asked all the time.
- Saying your favorite is
a little bit 14 year old.
So can I rephrase the question?
What are you watching at the moment, Joey?
- At the moment, I just
caught up on Attack on Titan.
- Okay. The whole damn thing?
- Well, I mean what it's up to currently.
Because, are you watching Attack on Titan?
- No, I watched through series one.
I haven't watched it since then.
- You're doing yourself a good service.
- It just gets better.
- Does it really?
- Yeah, it just gets better.
- Cause I started series two
and there was a lot of talking
and not much happening.
So I was a bit like.
- Season two is like
they throw in a lot of
politics into the story.
And it seems boring at first.
No, no. Trust me.
I think everyone was at that point.
- Don't you hate when
you're watching Peppa Pig
and they put in the fucking politics.
- Don't get me started.
Don't get me started.
- No, but like, I think
everyone was at that point
when season two started they were like,
Oh God, like where's the action?
Where's the high octane action
everyone came for from season one.
But then after a while, you
quickly start to realize,
Oh this is very important to the story.
And it just gets you more
invested in that world.
- It makes the world
more and more interesting
as you go along.
So by the time you get to season four
it's got the same action packed
kind of roller coaster ride.
But then you also really-
- The stakes are so much high.
- Yeah, the stakes are like way higher.
- Right.
What season are they up to now?
- Four.
- This feels like a
conversation with my dad.
No dad, it's anime, it's great.
- Calm down young Connor.
- What is the last anime you've watched?
- Connor, you know what
you stop doing, Connor
stop watching anime and read a good book.
(everyone laughing)
- Kids these days, they
watch too much anime.
- I'm one of, now I do
not want for a second
wanna take away from the
seriousness of the health crisis
of COVID-19, but one of the
advantages of this pandemic
has there's been a lot of time at home
to do things such as catch up on anime.
So I've been catching up on Aggretsuko.
- Oh, Aggretsuko's fantastic.
- Yeah. And Kengan Ashura.
- I haven't seen Kengan Ashura.
- You should watch Baki.
- Have you seen Baki?
- Please watch Baki.
- Everyone keeps telling me to watch Baki.
- I mean, you're a martial artist
like you should love Baki.
- I somehow didn't get into it
at the start for some reason.
- Keep going, keep going.
- Keep going.
- Okay. Here's a more important question.
Do you watch Jojo?
- Ah I don't.
- You would, you would
absolutely adore Jojo.
- You are literally a Jojo's character.
- You are a Jojo character.
- Why have I not been put
in this anime series yet?
- You could have been in the
Hong Kong dub for all we know.
- No, I haven't but you are now,
person number X whose
told me to watch that.
- You would absolutely love it.
- I mean if you go to the internet,
you get told to watch it.
- I potentially have no choice.
- Yeah. I mean, I think
you'll genuinely love it.
And I think with Baki as well like,
if you give it a little bit of a chance.
- But I gotta feeling the
reason I didn't get into Baki
was like, the DVD was broken.
- It's also on Netflix.
- It's on Netflix.
- That's why now this
excuse doesn't work anymore.
Yeah. But I've watched Kengan Ashura.
Do any of you watch that?
- No I haven't.
- No, no, no.
- I think this is blasphemy
for me to say like,
I just thought it was like inferior Baki.
- Did you watch it? You
watched the whole thing?
- I watched two episodes
and I was like, no.
- Is it cause of the 3D?
- I don't know.
I was just watching it and I was like,
every itch was scratched better by Baki.
- I feel that main character
whose name I can't remember
the little weeny dude.
- From Baki?
- No, no, no. From Kengan Ashura.
Because you haven't seen him.
Whoever he is,
I look at him and I'm
like, I know this man.
There's so many Japanese men
who are like that, you know?
- Oh, really?
- Just like.
I wish I was awesome.
Look at these awesome men.
I wish I was one, you know.
And therefore, I think I
have a personal connection.
- God I hate it when I'm on the train,
and someone just choking,
how awesome I am.
- You know what I'm saying?
- No, we don't.
We're not going to lie. We don't, no.
- I feel like something like that
has a certain essence of Japanese.
And there are so many
people in this country
who have been forced into a profession
or a series of activities
that they are not into.
And they just yearn to
be a different person.
- Right.
- And then they, whatever
they are they Otaku for
pro wrestling or anime
or idols whatever it is.
It's like, they get to
totally embrace that fantasy.
So to that end, Kengan Ashura actually,
despite the ridiculousness
of it feels quite real to me.
- Right.
- And I think I appreciate it now
because I've lived in
Japan for a long time.
- You're really selling
Kengan Ashura right now.
- I feel bad for calling it.
- You know what? You should,
you should my friend.
- I'll give it another shot.
- Do it. Give it another shot right now.
- So you said you've watched Aggretsuko
have you caught up to season three?
- No, not yet.
See I'm getting through them you see.
- I would be very interested
to see what your opinion
of season three is.
- Yeah.
- Dear me.
- Actually yeah, yeah.
You're right.
- I don't want to spoil you,
but let's say-
- The parallels are, astonishing.
- What? The parallels between
that and Kengan Ashura?
- No, no. Parallels between
the season three and you.
- All right, all right.
- I'll be interested.
I'll be interested to see.
- Well I'll watch the rest of Aggretsuko.
You watch Kengan Ashura,
we'll come back and do another podcast.
- No, okay. Here's the
thing I've always wanted to
I just hadn't had the time to
like sit down and watch it.
- So now it was my understanding
that you watched literally every anime.
- No, actually.
- Well in that case, my
understanding was incorrect.
- Yeah.
- Where did you get
that understanding from?
Was it from his name?
- Was it from my name?
- The Anime Man.
- Yeah, I remember when I first met you.
I remember you being like,
yeah, I watched every anime.
- Well yeah.
(everyone laughing)
- That was also during, wow,
way to out me out like that.
That was also.
- Sorry, sorry. I'm sorry.
- No, no, no.
But like, I think because
when I did meet you,
it was like what, 2015, 2016, right?
Back then I literally
did watch everything,
but that's because, that was also the time
when I also wasn't as busy as I was now.
Like I think the one
reason I just can't anymore
is because I just have
so much shit going on.
- And I was wondering how you managed
to maintain that level
of sitting on a couch
when you're doing so many things.
Like, Oh, by the way, I
watched the video of you guys
riding bicycles across Japan.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh God.
- It's very clear to me you don't spend
most of the time at the gym.
It's wonderful, wonderful.
It was a masterpiece.
But I was wondering how
you managed to keep up
that level of consumption
when your output was so great.
- He doesn't.
- I don't.
- Now, and this is interesting.
I think one of the
interesting things about
becoming content is the lifestyle
that is required to be content
is the opposite of the lifestyle required
to consume content.
- Yeah.
- Hundred percent.
- Hundred percent. I'd agree with that.
- And I think the best way,
the best like,
metaphor I guess for it.
So you think about professional sports,
the lifestyle of the guys on the field
is the polar opposite from the lifestyle
of the people on the stands.
People on the stands with
their beer and their hotdogs
swearing and screaming.
Guys on the field getting up
at 5:00 AM and doing sprints.
Eating like salad.
I feel that's the same way
when you're doing content.
It's like you say, when you got into it
as a consumer, you then
become the content.
- Right.
- And now you are to be consumed.
- And that's I guess the dilemma right?
Well, I mean, exactly.
But like that's also
just the dilemma of being
an anime content creator right?
It's like, I need to watch
anime to create content
but because I'm too busy creating content
I don't have enough time to watch anime.
- It's a paradox.
- It's a catch-22.
- It's a catch-22, exactly.
And I've just been trying
so hard to I guess like
just try and keep up as much as possible,
but without having to go down to like,
a video every two months. Right.
So it's just like.
- Call me out on that.
- Well, no, you're getting
way better at a recently.
Yeah. You're getting way
better recently right?
- Are you a bit slow with your uploads?
- I mean like, I, my upload
schedule is like way longer
than neither of these two,
but I mean that's because.
- But he also like jam packs
like a lot more into one video.
- I was gonna say, your videos
are quite long, aren't they?
- Yeah, and they're all scripted as well.
Where these two just turn on the camera
and just start talking.
- Talking shit.
Yeah, literally, yeah.
- I remember the first time I helped
I think Joey record one of his videos
and we recorded like a tier list.
And he turned on the camera.
We just started talking
for an hour and a half.
Turns it off and he goes, all right, done.
My work here is done, I'm just
like, What? That was a video?
- But yeah, just send it to
my editor now, we're good.
- Well, there's the rare
instances where you're like
this is just amazing cause
I got one of my weekly
uploads done in an hour.
And it required no planning,
but then other times it's like
I have to set up so many fucking things.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've got to go to X time
with X person, film this blah, blah, blah.
- Get permission, absolute
nightmare sometimes.
- So how did this transition happen
from doing anime content
into your going out
into the world and doing
interesting Japan things content.
- I think, I don't know about you, Joey.
But I never wanted to be
stuck in my room doing stuff.
But it's like, it's the means
that you have at that time.
It's like when I was creating content
I always envisioned something bigger.
That was more involved with me doing stuff
and moving to Japan and
having an agency help
was pretty much the key
to allowing me to do that.
- I think for me it was
more so because, you know
I have the problem with my
name being the Anime Man.
People just expect me to just be,
every video I'm in my
room talking about anime.
So I always, cause I always
had like so many ideas
to do other things that
no matter how much I
thought about it I was like,
there's no way I can
twist anime into this.
So I might as well just not make it.
But then this year, especially
I was like, ah fuck it.
Like if I enjoy it and it's
just seems interesting enough
and I can have a fun time doing it then
I'm just gonna make it.
Yeah.
- That drifting video you
did was fricking cool.
- It was a great video.
- Thank you very much.
- I watched that drifting video.
I was like, Hm, I wanna go drift.
- I mean, yeah. It's really fun.
- It's expensive.
- It's really expensive.
- It's very expensive.
- Beyond via shinkansen it's expensive.
Like the drifting itself.
- Yes.
- Is it really?
- Yeah. I mean Alexi
who we had on as guest,
he's like a professional drifter.
But like, yeah he said like,
it's one of the most
expensive hobbies out there.
- Yeah cause you're basically
tearing apart a car.
- We were able to like rent cars.
But most of the time, if you want to drift
you have to buy a car.
- Because they expect you,
because they expect that car
to be just total by the end of it.
- Damn.
- So you buy a car and it just
sits on their parking lots
and you can use it whenever you want.
- And then you got to replace
the tires like every session.
- Of course, and I imagine
there's safety standards
that have to be maintained like a beast.
- Surprisingly.
- Really? Not seatbelt
regulations and things?
- Safety is like, it's
up to you, you know.
I don't know if that I
could be completely wrong.
I kinda got that vibe.
- I got the vibe when
you didn't even need a driving license
to go to the drift track.
- It's private property. So you can.
- It's like driving in someone's backyard.
- Cause Garnt doesn't
have a license to drive
And Joey doesn't have a license to drive.
- I do have a license to
drive but not in Japan.
- So we booked this thing.
And I remember there was
a big concern like, wait
but these two doesn't have licenses,
what are we going to do?
- Because we thought we
needed like a manual license
and Garnt and I don't, we only
have an automatic license.
- Oh no, Garnt can drive manual, right?
- Yeah, I can drive manual.
- I don't have a manual
license so I was like,
well I'm gonna be screwed.
And the guy was like,
no, you don't need it.
Just jump in.
- You're fine.
- Just learn.
So I had to learn manual
like, on the spot.
- And it was horrible.
- It's very funny.
- When I learnt manual, it was for a movie
I shot in the Philippines.
- The tangent, here comes the tangent.
- Wait, wait for fuck sake.
Okay. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
- And I learned how to drive manual.
- I briefly lived in the Philippines.
And I worked for a movie studio,
and I was a producer and an actor.
And so I was acting in a particular film.
- What haven't you done?
- I literally asked you
like half an hour ago.
Is there any other like jobs
that you haven't mentioned yet?
- When did you go undercover in a gang?
And bust a drug ring. Can
you tell me about that?
- Interestingly, that's
why I'm at this podcast,
to bust the anime man.
So the way I learned manual
was I had to learn it for this movie
and I'm not a stunt driver.
I'd never done stunts in cars ever.
And they're like, yeah, so that's the car.
And would get this guy who will
teach how to drive a manual.
I've never driven manual.
Keep in mind, it's also on
the wrong side of the road
from Australia.
So the steering wheel is on
the other side of the car.
So right there and I spent a few days
clickitty clacking, bunny
hoping away, learn how to do it.
And then in the movie, the
scene that I have to shoot
with me in the car is like
dirt track in this dodgy
like countryside Philippines.
It's like through the middle
of like a rice paddies.
So it's like, there's the road
and then like a drop on either side.
- Right, right.
- And I have to like,
come out this corner,
speed it up, get up to
like 60 or something
going directly at the camera crew.
And then they're gonna
pull back on the dolly
at the last second I had to
go and like whiz around them.
- Jesus Christ.
- And I'm like, you want a
non-stunt driver to do that?
You really want a
non-stunt to do that shot?
- Did you have to sign any
health and safety stuff or?
- In Philippines?
(everyone laughing)
- Nothing's happen in Japan,
and you're thinking the Philippines
has got a health and safely disclaimer?
So we got for it.
I'm sitting there before the
first taken I'm like, well.
- Rip camera man.
- Vehicular manslaughter?
How long is that in prison?
- I'm having an adventure if nothing else.
So, but what would happen
is this camera crew
as they pulled out on their dolly,
one of the guys would
jump out onto the road
to pull the fricking camera.
Didn't tell me he would do that.
- Right.
- So okay, you're directions is speed up,
get to 60 then on the last
second, just whiz around them.
- Right.
- No Rehearsals?
- No.
(imitating car noises)
- I'm up 60 at this guy, okay.
Getting there, freaking out a little bit.
Do my zing to get around him.
And then a man jumps in front of the car.
Ahh!
- Jesus Christ.
- Did you hit him?
- Did you kill him?
- Finally, I didn't.
But then another take, a
homeless man jumped on the road.
Out of the rice paddy onto the road.
- What the fuck.
- Oh my God.
Oh my God.
- You have lived like
the experience of like 10
different lives at least.
It's fucking crazy.
- It's ridiculous.
- Oh my God.
- I just want to sit in front
of a fire with a cup of tea.
- Yeah. I do too.
After the interesting talks
you've told us, Jesus Christ.
But I guess, to wrap things up like
where do you want our viewers
to go check your stuff out.
- Go check out Ladybeard on
the social medias, Ladybeard.
That's one word underscore Japan.
Ladybeard underscore
Japan on the twippy twappy
and the facie bookie and the Instamagram
and the old ticking tocking.
And don't forget to check out
Ladybeard's new group, Babybeard.
Coming at you on all those same places.
2021. Prepare yourself world.
It's on like Donkey
mother loving Kong! Ah!
- I love the G-rating self censoring.
- G-rating.
- That's the G-rating right there.
- Donkey Kong loves his mama, mama Kong.
I would like to say a huge thank you,
to you members of the
rubbish rebel podcast
for having me on your
established media today.
- No, no, no, thank you for
having us on your podcast.
- It might as well we be in your podcast.
- When you see the comparison
between your subscribers and mine,
you will quickly realize
it's your podcast.
I'd like to thank you
gentlemen, sincerely.
It's wonderful to have this conversation.
- Thank you.
- I'd like to thank our
behind the scenes crew.
Let's just have a round
of applause very quick,
for our behind the scenes crew.
They've done an excellent job.
And lastly, I'd like to thank you.
The viewers is of Trash
Taste podcast, without you-
- Is this an Oscar's speech? What is this?
- We didn't have to do anything.
- Yeah we didn't have to do anything.
- Without you, this show isn't possible.
- You've got to thank the patrons.
- You have to thank the patrons.
- We got patrons?
- Yeah we got patrons.
- I'm saying we like it's my show.
I'd like to thank our patrons,
your names are coming up here.
- You got it, you got it. There you go.
- Don't forget to like
comment and subscribe.
On the box below.
- Shout out the Twitter and subreddit.
- What?
- We have a Twitter and a subreddit.
- A shout out to your
Twitter and your subreddit.
- And we have a Spotify as well.
- Spotify?
Don't forget to subscribe
to the Trash Taste podcast
on Spotify.
- There you go.
- I'm Ladybeard and
I'll see you next time.
- You just did our job for us like.
- I guess that's it, bye guys.
- [Joey, Garnt And Connor] Bye.
(chill outro music playing)